[Music]
all right YouTube we are live with the
man who I think at this point needs no
introduction
Jordan Peterson welcome back this is
number four if we count our live event
at Clemson two weeks ago this is your
fourth appearance on the Rubin report
amazing that we can think of anything to
talk about
I much time you think we're gonna figure
out something well you you were both
pretty noisy so I imagine we'll probably
figure out something people say you know
Peterson he's talking a lot could you
think perhaps in the course of this hour
hour and a half we could get you to the
end you know could you run out of words
I don't know I had a reputation when I
was like four years old for never not
talking so I don't think it's gonna go
away that's like fifty-one years ago so
well it's funny because I just did a
behind-the-scenes video that we put up
for our patrons only today is actually a
very special day for me because November
1st 2016 is the day that I moved into
this house and and started building this
studio which took a couple weeks and you
were actually my first guest oh yeah
right
while we were between studios I had to
do it in the other room we did it on
Google hangout there was crappy internet
connection instruction noise there was
construction noise I could barely hear
you at points I couldn't see you and it
was really my intro to you I actually
didn't know that much about you at the
time you had just sort of come on the
map in a newer way so we did that one
then we've done a live sit down here
than we did Clemson and here we are
again two weeks later and yeah well it's
a good deal we got a lot to get to we do
you're writing a new book coming out in
January right you bet ended January I
think the 23rd I think is when it comes
out it's already yeah so yeah I'm pretty
happy both that so you sent me the the
advance copy PDF is that the official
advance copy there's a little bit of
changes since then but the actual
galleys will be ready within a week I
think it goes to print next week yeah
what we've known a few illustrations and
then it's ready to go yeah so as an
interviewer you actually made my job
really easy today because your chapters
I told you before we started your
chapters are so perfect that each one I
think we can lay into a question here
but I want to start with some other
stuff first guys we just did Clemson
about two weeks ago it was a great event
it was totally sold out kids sit
in the in the stairwell try you know
because there was no more room in the
chairs and all that did you walk out of
there feeling as positive about the
college stuff as me because we know
about all the bad stuff we all read it
all the time and we see all the all the
terrible stuff on college campuses but I
really leave a lot of the events that I
do feeling good the more bad a lot of
the stuff that's that's unsavory let's
say is the work of a very small minority
of students I mean this is true
particularly perhaps not particularly
but it's it's certainly true of the
University of Toronto which is I would
say like a center conservative
institution as far as the students are
concerned most of them are children of
first-generation immigrants like there
they've got their eye on the prize you
know they spend most of their time
working it's not a party school it's not
a radical school but there's a small
percentage of radical people including
people who come in from outside the
university to cause trouble and a small
number of radical disciplines and it
doesn't take that many people who are
really focused on activism to produce an
effect that's far beyond their their
numerical significance and so it and you
know you don't want to give University
kids a bad name because the vast
majority of them I think are I don't
think they're any less hard-working for
example than the baby boomers yeah quite
the contrary in my in my estimation so
yeah I usually go to the universities
and come away with a positive feeling
you know so and Clemson was certainly an
event like that yeah what do you make of
the ability for that small minority to
affect such a big amount of people you
had a tweet about a shepherd it only
take it doesn't take very many dogs to
to shepherd a lot of sheep yeah how is
it that they've been able to do that
because when we go out there I mean look
we did that QA for an hour after we had
and we had to end it early because they
they literally meet you know they needed
the room they were kicking us yeah but
there were still 50 people that want to
ask us questions we waited we stayed
around for another hour and still we had
they had to drag us out I mean you could
have done it all night long but what do
you make of that that little group that
has somehow they're really good at it
they've been like first of all you know
that the the radical leftist position
that they put forward has been an
activist move
and since let's say mmm before the
Russian Revolution right I mean it's not
like the ground hasn't been prepared for
this sort of thing and the disciplines
that are leading this like Women's
Studies for example they're activist
disciplines they train people to do this
but that's what they do it's pretty much
all they do except not educating then
propagandizing them feeding them you
know sets of Lies and and
oversimplifying the universe in a in a
radical way so in and so it doesn't
that's the thing it doesn't take that
many people who are committed to a cause
to have a impact beyond their numbers
and I think that might even be more true
with the onset of social media so do you
think that's why what you're doing is is
sort of hitting it the way it is because
you're basically I mean obviously you
can explain post-modernism and Marxism
and all of that stuff but really what
you're telling people is to own their
own life I mean from the even from the
amount of your book that I was able to
read today that to me seems to be the
the thrust of what you're doing you're
saying it's sort of get your [ __ ]
together and then deal with all this
other stuff yeah well I'd be not I don't
really consider myself in some sense a
political person and I mean that really
in a very particular way I've thought
about a political career many times
during my life I worked for a political
party when I was a kid you know I like
14 and quite intently but what party was
it was it was a Socialist Party in Guam
the MDP that was back then a new
Democratic Party which is part of the
mainstream and Canadian politics that
was back when I would say they were a
valid voice for the working-class you
know and I knew the leadership of the of
the provincial party and the National
Party to some degree I had some access
because the person who was our
representative was the leader of the
Alberta NDP and I knew him and his wife
quite well and they were at the upper
echelon of the party at least at that
time those people were actually
concerned with giving the working class
a voice like it was a genuine it was a
genuine they were genuinely committed to
that but I noticed that the lower level
punk party functionaries he
I didn't like them much and I couldn't
put my finger on it until I read George
Orwell and you know Orwell said he was
criticizing British socialists even
though he was a socialist himself he
said well typical British middle-class
socialist doesn't like the poor they
just hate the rich it's like and that
was that was exactly the feeling I got
that this this so-called sympathy
empathy let's say for the oppressed had
a hell of a lot more to do with
vengefulness and resentment with regards
to the to anyone who was seen as having
privilege and I certainly think that
that's just and I was thinking about
that the other day I just did a talk in
DC and I was thinking about you know the
Marxist claims to sympathy worth the
working class because you might say well
they actually have sympathy for the
working class are they really trying to
put their their their their positions
forward their needs forward or do they
just hate the successful depending on
how that's divided up I thought well how
do you make a judgment like that and I
have this personal experience but then I
thought well that's easy with Marxism
it's like you just look at all the
murders and you then you know whether
that was a movement that was genuinely
motivated by empathy right a lot of
people died in all of this leftist yeah
a lot yeah like an unbelievable number
and and not just members of the
oppressor class let's say mm-hmm like
everyone and it happens over and over
you know and it's really worth thinking
about because well when you might don't
think well is that somehow embedded in
the Marxist doctrine is it an inevitable
consequence of the unfolding of these
ideas that someone like Iran for example
would say definitely and Solzhenitsyn
made that case too and the Gulag
Archipelago but it's not self-evident
but I think there's a level under which
underneath the ideas that you could go
and say what's motivating this is it
actually like saintly compassion for the
downtrodden or is it resentment about
the fact that life is unfair and tragic
which it definitely is it is well you
know by their fruits you shall know them
that's the answer to that question it's
like well if 3040 million people die in
the aftermath of the revolution and a
tremendous number them
ordinary people and that happens
repeatedly it's like a hole well I guess
it must be resentment and hatred like
how else do you account for all of that
the proof is in the pudding so to speak
well if you know and if you're not
willing to accept that sort of thing as
proof you're gonna also ask like well
okay what would you allow to falsify
your theory like how many corpses have
to stack up yeah you think
and the numbers the number is pretty
high already so it's it's uncountable
yeah you know like we don't know we
don't know how many people died as a
consequence of communist totalitarianism
it could be 50 million it could be 150
million those are big error bars yeah
you know like that's that's a big that's
a big problem when you can't count in
the tens of millions when you can't get
the damn estimate right and it happened
in multiple cultures right because you
might say well it was just specific to a
time in place it wasn't intrinsic to
this radical doctrine yeah well there's
not that much it's the same about the
Soviet Union and all of its countries
let's say broad range of cultures Mao is
China
Cambodia you know places in Africa as
well these aren't the same places but
nonetheless you drop that poisonous seed
in there and it's like mayhem no time
flat and nothing works like it's so so
I'm going for the don't be thinking that
you're so saintly just because you claim
to stand for the oppressed it's like you
examine your conscience and well that
thing that thing though is a drug to
people right I mean that you know what
we refer to as virtue signaling and all
that but that that feeling that you're
always looking out for everyone else
you'll always sacrifice yourself for
anyone else you'll always attack the the
privileged and suppose it people above
you it really there's something in that
that that has like an addictive quality
well the question is what's the drug you
know the question the drug might be oh
I'm a good person
maybe but like a more psychoanalytically
minded person might say no that's not
actually the drug the drug is the hatred
and the rationalization for the use of
power and that and that and the wish for
totalitarian control and tyrannical rule
that the
that the Maskull mask of virtue covers
so the virtue signaling actually that's
that's not what's really providing the
big kick you know it's like I'm a good
person it's like no it's even better
than this it's like I've got a place to
direct my worst my worst impulses I
don't even have to notice them myself
because I've got this mask of virtue and
so I can let let's call them you know
the demonic forces that make up part of
the human psyche I can let them have
carte blanche and and then also say that
I'm virtuous you know I would that's a
powerful combination yeah well it looks
like it's a powerful combination I mean
if you if you look at the way people
behave historically speaking it it looks
I mean it's often then that great
horrors are perpetrated by people who
mask them in a utopian covering right
right nobody no-nobody comes out and
says hey well I'm out here to do harm
right that isn't what people but but
somehow harm gets done yeah and so you
know one of the things I really like
about the American political system is
that it's it's not predicated on a
utopian ideal you know the founders of
the American system of course they were
basically English but you know the
founders the American system said okay
well you know you can't trust people to
do the right thing it doesn't mean
they're all bad hmm you can't assume
that they're gonna do the utopian thing
now isn't what people are like and they
tend to take care of themselves first
and maybe that's okay maybe it's not but
it has to be bounded but given what we
know about the imperfection of
individuals and societies let's try to
build a system that no idiot can screw
up too badly yeah and I think I was a
mature man it's so it's so
psychologically informed and and so wise
it's like no Alan we're not aiming for
the utopia will aim for for not to
murderous how about that
right and that's the thing because
humans are the flaw in the utopian
system right I mean you can't create
utopia because we're part of it and we
are not perfect well is the idea of the
perfect system created by an imperfect
creature us it actually doesn't even
stand her
yeah well then you can't also blame our
imperfections on the imperfect social
structure which is of course what the
Marxist tend to do because he doesn't
help it's like okay the social structure
is imperfect well who produced that it
just pushes the question right like one
step earth you know and so so while I
said at the beginning of this that are
not specifically political and I haven't
been addressing everything that's been
going on except when I drift I would say
politically I think instead no no the
right thing to do is this is what I'm a
psychologist it's like the right level
of focus is the individual and what
individuals can do first is like what a
physician should do first do no harm
right like assume that you know you're
probably a force for mayhem in trouble
unless you've got yourself disciplined
in ain't right
you know because you're complicated and
troublesome and so unless you've got
your act together you're trouble and
everyone knows that and they know people
like that so the first thing you do is
constrain the amount of damage you're
likely to do and you do that by
disciplining yourself and by also
admitting to yourself that you don't
know what you're doing that there's lots
of things about you that need to be
improved which is actually that's a
beacon of hope right it's like well my
life is miserable yeah but you're doing
a bunch of things wrong it's like oh
good because if I'm doing a bunch of
things wrong then maybe if I fix them my
life won't be so horrible well that's
good and everyone knows about the fact
that they're not doing things right
fundamentally you know they don't have
to examine their conscience that much to
figure that out and then you can start
aiming for something something good
start not lying any more than you have
to or maybe not at all if you can train
yourself then you start to discern truth
from falsehood and then you can find out
empirically does your life get better or
worse well you know I've got hundreds of
letters now maybe thousands of letters
from people who have been trying that
you know and they say well you know I'm
Way better doesn't do it way better than
you know I went into her then I thought
that I was before I went into a
restaurant the other day in Toronto and
this kid came up and he shook my hand
and he said I just
you know that since I've been listen to
you I've got three promotions at this
restaurant huh and I said well you know
good work man like way to be and he said
yeah well I started coming in on time
and I'm working really hard and I'm
trying to figure out how I can do a good
job here instead of being above the job
you know I'll take this until I get
something better it's sort of beneath me
it's like no probably not actually it's
not that easy to do most jobs it's
actually hard to do most jobs especially
to do them well and it turns out that
the world is constituted if society is
set up well that if you do a good job
invisible doors open in front of you
because people and I know this I've had
lots of contact with businesses and
academic institutions and like the
people who run things competently are
often but not always interested very
interested in finding young people that
they can mentor and move forward it's
actually one of the pleasures of being
competent than something yeah and so if
they see someone who's like going that
extra mile you know busy people have
lots of opportunities around them and
they think oh I've got that opportunity
I can't really do it but I can funnel it
over to this kid here yeah like let's
see how he or she does it you know and
so you think yeah you want to try this
and the person says well I don't have
time it's like oh well okay but the
smart kid says yeah yes yes I'll do that
and then the person with opportunities
thinks watch isn't thinks okay well
let's you know but back up bit see if
person does it and if they do it it's
like hey here's four more opportunities
that I don't have time for it's like
bang I would venture to say that every
single person listening to this live
right now knows that's the truth because
I can think of so many examples in my
life especially when I started doing
stand-up the crazy odd jobs that I did
every little thing that I could do to
make a dime just so I could keep the
dream coming and then that eventually it
opens doors it closes doors you get
trapped doors but you just keep moving
so in an odd way this post-modernism
stuff the the idea of that the system's
rigged against you they're really
actually stealing
something from young people right there
they're stealing or stealing their
future there but there but they're also
stealing like their intestinal fortitude
you're stealing their ability to go I've
got to make something in this one yeah
well on your optimism it's like no look
the system is rigged against you okay
you're gonna die you're gonna be ill
like it's rough man
now you don't want to lay that at the
feet of the social structure because the
social structure at least in part is
trying to have you not die right I mean
that's why we have walls and electricity
and all of that and works pretty damn
well you know you're probably going to
live till you're 80 and the only reason
you're not going to live longer is
because we can't figure out how to get
you to live longer that's why you're not
gonna starve to death
wild animals aren't gonna tear you in
pieces tyrants aren't gonna rip you from
limb to limb it's like these are good
things now you still got a big problem
because the cosmic system is rigged
against you in a sense but okay so fine
what do you mean by that the cop you
know you're vulnerable and and and and
and and you can be broken and you will
be in many ways mm-hmm but you can't
blame someone for that it's just that's
the structure of reality okay so what do
you do about that well as far as I can
tell and I've always looked as a
psychologist for optimistic ideas and
and I'm not it's not I'm not an easy
sell with regards to optimistic ideas
especially because of my basic belief
and the idea that you know the most
profound truth is that life is suffering
it's ok fine life is suffering you can't
blame that on anyone
all right so what do you do about it
well maybe nothing maybe nothing maybe
the jig's up it's hopeless you know but
maybe that's not right maybe here's
something what do you have against the
suffering and the malevolence let's say
you have possibility you have potential
in front of you inside of you even
whatever that means so here's the
question what would your life be like if
you made use of all the potential that
you were offered that's the optimistic
question because you can test it out say
ok well I'll just try that for a year
I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna do the best I
can at everything that offers itself to
me just as an experiment
then I'm gonna see well is my life
better or is my life worse it's like I
tried for a year you think huh it's
actually better my friendships are
better my family is better I'm I'm less
anxious I'm more positively oriented I'm
less resentful and bitter and jealous
and angry you know I'm more physically
healthy it's like hey great and you
still you're not that good at it it's
like what happens if you did that for
five years yeah that's a good addiction
that's an addiction yeah yeah it's an
addiction to possibility and then it's
also an exponential thing and this is
actually technically true we know this
beyond a shadow of a doubt there's this
principle that economists talk about
they often call it the Matthew principle
which is based on a statement in the New
Testament from those who have everything
no yeah
to those who have everything more will
be given and from those who have nothing
everything will be taken it's really a
vicious statement but what it means is
as you go downhill you go downhill
faster and faster and people know that
it's like it isn't linear man it's
exponential you do one thing
stupid then two stupid things happen
then four stupid things happen and it's
you know before you know it
you're done but the reverse of that is
also true you do one good thing and then
you know you get two opportunities and
you fix them up and you get four and
this is how the world works it's a
fundamental economic principle and you
see because of that that a small
proportion of people have most of the
gains accrue to them and they're the
ones they're healthy that's luck often
you know they didn't get run over by a
boss like there's lots arbitrary things
about life that have to go right but
after that it's like those are also
people who are capitalizing on what
they're being offered without bitterness
or resentment and then maybe it won't
work for you but you don't have a better
you don't have a better plan than that
don't it's interesting cuz as you're
saying this I'm just reminded of a line
that my grandma said to me once in in
her later years when she was in her mid
80s health was failing she had cancer
and heart disease and several other
things and I saw her she was trying to
get up from the couch and she was
struggling to get up and I tried to help
her and she didn't want help and she
said god helps those who help themselves
she wasn't a particularly religious
person in any way or even spiritual that
I that I knew of in any particular way
she was traditional but not predict a
religious but I thought that Steve
at first it didn't make sense to me why
wouldn't you want your grandsons help to
get up if you're ugly but then it did
make sense to me I think maybe years
later I finally understood it and I
think it sort of fits well with what
you're saying here but putting the god
part of it aside she knew she had to
help herself that you have to help
yourself yeah well because otherwise
you'll become dependent either on your
grandchild or you up or the entire
system propping you up or whatever it is
well that's the Freudian eatable
nightmare really is like hey mom does
everything for me it's like oh really
you know that's not so good because that
means you can't do anything for yourself
you know and so there's a rule for
working with old people in elde age
homes and the rule is don't do anything
for the for the residents that they can
do themselves you think well that's
pretty harsh it's like no it isn't
you're you're helping them retain their
independence and their strength right
yeah you're not stealing their strength
and it's the same with little kids like
little kids should be doing whatever
they can that's productive and useful as
young as they can like if you have a
two-year-old
it's just totaling around you know you
can get that two-year-old to set the
table like we used to have our kids do
that's really funny to watch it because
the tables like half above their heads
right so you know you give the
two-year-old a knife not a sharp one
obviously that's a different
psychological game save that for next
time Peterson yeah exactly
you know and you say okay go put this on
the table no they can't exactly put it
beside the plate because they can't see
the damn plate right but they're the
kids are actually if you're careful with
them and you you adjust your
expectations to their level of
developing expertise that's called the
zone of proximal development by the way
they're they're more than happy to to
comply because it helps them develop and
move forward and they have a really
powerful instinct for them you know when
with kids it's also interesting if you
if you watch them very carefully you can
see when they're ready for the next task
you know and then also the kids you know
people talk a lot about self-esteem
which is it
it's very badly conceptualized
self-esteem because it it's come to me
and you should feel good about yourself
which I don't believe I think you should
feel good about who you who you could be
if you got your act together and you
shouldn't be feeling so good about who
you are now in your story state it's
like what the hell man you're 17 don't
be feeling too good about yourself get
the hell get your art together and see
what you could be and feel good about
your trajectory yeah that's way
different but also your confidence and
so lucky even with little kids is they
know they're being taken care of they
have an existential depth to their
parents is like if you allow them to be
useful and encourage them to do things
then they get to pay off that
existential debt and then they can see
that they're contributing members of
even this small society and it's no lie
it's like hey you know when our daughter
was when my son was born my daughter was
about a year and a half old and you can
get pretty intense sibling rivalry with
with kids aren't separated by three
years it doesn't mean you should
separate them by three years but but
because the older kid is still pretty
dependent so you got to watch that so
the first thing we did was we talked to
her about the new baby that was coming
and we told her that that was going to
be her baby you know as well as our baby
that's your baby
and then we taught her to get a hug and
we had her act that outs like okay when
when the new baby comes there's gonna be
times when your mom is preoccupied you
gotta say it the way a three-year-old
one and a half year old something like
that was one and a half can understand
and that means acting it out and playing
right like pretend play but the message
was there'll be times when you're gonna
feel lonesome and you have to come and
get a hug well so then we'd have her
practice it's like let's play a game
pretend you're lonesome it's like okay
now come and get a hug it's like okay
this is better than the knife game I
think it's better than the knife game
well and so okay so far and then we had
our new our son and we helped Mikaela my
daughter figure out how to take care of
him and you know when one and a half
year old can actually take care of a
baby they can watch the baby and if the
baby cries they can come and tug on you
you know say the baby needs you know
whatever the baby needs and so then well
then they're the older child also gets a
set of privileges because of that it's
like well you're older you don't get to
be an infant anymore that's kind of
sucks because mums with you all the time
it's like what do you get in exchange
you get some more freedom you get some
more status you get some more power it's
like it's a good trade-off that's why
you want to grow that's where you want
to become an adult
want to steal that from people it's you
steal theirs it's that's hence that's
that's the witch and Hansel and Gretel
who fattens up the kids and eats them
it's like compared to my lair for the
one it's gingerbread and candy yeah you
won't have to do anything I'll take care
of you that's like yeah run away from
that person yeah a lot of what you're
talking about sounds like Montessori
type teaching to me I have a niece who's
about two and a half very much you know
you have to whatever you take out of the
box in the classroom you have to put
away the exact way you got it and then
you can keep learning you know it's just
sort of a very it's progressive in the
good sense right progressive which is
like um a dirty developmentally
progressive zone that doesn't
progressive yeah well when you're like I
have a chapter in this book called don't
allow your children to do anything that
makes you dislike them don't go too far
into that right I want to get to all 12
okay okay um do you think that there's a
right number of children to have as
you're saying that that popped in my
head I come from part one is a good
number and the reason for that now if
you have one child it's like I'm not
saying well that's terrible man like
what the hell is wrong with you
right that's hard yeah have one child
because children first of all socialize
each other and they amuse each other and
so we've found so we have two kids and
then my wife also took care of a couple
of neighbor kids that actually in some
ways made things easier because the kids
will just run off and amuse themselves
and then what you have to be is around
when they have a problem but they don't
want you around and you don't
necessarily want them around you have
adult things to do right with one child
you've got the problem of having to
amuse the child all the time and the
child has the problem of not having
siblings to hash things out at at a
peer-to-peer level and I think that
maybe that one of the reasons the
overprotected child you know going to
university phenomena has emerged is
because children are now mostly produced
by older couples so who are more intent
on doing everything right for them but
they also don't have enough siblings so
they're not getting sort of you know
they're like puppies that haven't had
enough rough-and-tumble play with other
puppies yeah it
they're really like that I mean and
that's not good we know from the animal
developmental studies like even with
rats social animals don't do that well
unless they have peers to get into it
with you know and a lot of socialization
takes place between peers and so so I
would say to kids minimum because well
then then you have kids and they can
amuse each other and maybe three is nice
and you know but one is one is I do not
believe that one is easier than two I
don't believe that we talked a little
bit about this over a drink we had a
couple weeks ago but what about the
couples that have no kids couples that
just say you know we're more interested
in our intellectual pursuits or
traveling or something you think they're
really missing sort of like a key
component of of what life is right I do
I really believe that I mean I think
they don't I think the kids have a bad
rap that's the problem that's also why I
wrote this chapter in part because you
know you see this to a lot of Hollywood
depictions of children's very rare that
you see children portrayed nobly in a in
a in a Hollywood film you kind of saw it
with Harry Potter I like that and that's
partly why that was so popular I mean
those kids had some you know there were
bad kids and there were good kids and
their heroic kids like they were treated
pretty in some sense realistically given
that it was such a magical you know
enterprise and and but they had some
courage and they had some heart and they
had some rebellious nough sand so so I
like that but the thing that you have to
understand about kids is they're
unbelievably good company you know and
so they pay you back for your care of
them and by being ridiculously amusing
they're their little clouds and they're
doing crazy little stunts all the time
and they have a sense of humor that
kicks in like I have a grandchild now
that's two and a half months old and
that child can already smile and has the
beginnings of a sense of humor and
that's to me that's a miracle yes that's
pretty it is it and so they're very
funny they're really playful they really
really like you and you can have the
kind of relationship with them that you
set out to have and
that's very very interesting now and you
can also like once I had little kids I
spent a lot more time with them than I
did with my friends
say and the reason for that was that I
actually found it more enjoyable to do
things with little kids than with the
adults and the reason for that is like
by the time you're 30 say you've seen so
much of the world that you actually
don't see the world anymore and this is
technically true like I'm old I'm 55
when I walk down the street there's
houses I don't look at them I have house
icons in my memory and I just see the
house icons and and so the the older you
get in some sense the more what you see
of the world is your memory and that's
kind of its efficient but it's sort of
dead you know and and artists help break
through that they show you something as
if it's new again you know and and so
that's why Van Gogh's irises you know
sell for 160 million dollars it's like
you haven't looked at flowers since you
were three yeah okay so the thing that's
cool about having a little kid is
everywhere you go because we're so good
at putting ourselves in other people's
bodies the kid revitalizes the world and
the kids like oh I mean that's what a
two-year-old looks like all the time
right they're just completely awestruck
by everything and you can see that again
and that's really interesting man I I
know you know about my love of Star Wars
but I watched Empire Strikes Back with
my five-year-olds of the time nephew and
at the moment when Darth Vader told Luke
II was his father I was staring at him
and you have Star Wars yeah and I was
looking at him and the way his eyes
opened I was like wow like what that
that thing like that's what it's all
about right that's what it's all like as
an adult how could I ever as a 41 year
old have that experience again and
that's what you're talking about about
already and and a movie is art oh yeah
absolutely well I took my daughter to
see the mask with Jim Carrey when she
gravely a little bit young for that yeah
and I held her on my lap during I think
she was she was probably only about five
maybe something like that but I took her
out one night we went saw the mask and
it's pretty intense
like holding a what would you call a
bundle of electrically charged barbed
wire fence hour-and-a-half she was
kissing I like that and like I said it
was perhaps a bit much for her but I
haven't had the knife it was a hole yeah
well yeah exactly
but I mean you you forget how much
impact the world has and you know if you
bring little kids around old people you
can really see this cuz old people will
sit around like wouldn't we first had my
daughter when she was the first
grandchild on my side we take her up to
this lake that I go to see my parents
that way the hell up at northern Alberta
and she was like a little fire you know
how people sit around a fire and look at
it they can't look away
it's cuz we're all the descendants of
the first crazy chimpanzee who couldn't
keep his goddamnit all that fire you
know and that's what little kids are
like and and the older people just watch
them non-stop and it's partly because
they're participating in that renewal of
the world you know which is like it's
like a reintroduction to the unsullied
paradise of being something like that
and but it only works if he if you like
your kids and so there's a disciplinary
element that's really important too and
one of the things that modern parents
don't understand and I think this is
because of the exceptionally permissive
ethos of the 1960s when we developed
this idea that everything that society
does to children is bad
mm-hmm and so don't damage your children
like by putting restrictions on them
it's like that's just that's so wrong
that it's almost impossible it's why
people shy away from kids because they
don't understand that you don't have to
put up with any unpleasant you don't
have to put up with any unnecessary
unpleasant nonsense from children it's
not necessary it's interesting so that
you could almost argue that the the
sixties led to exactly what you're
talking about these kids who then were
taught to be afraid of everything they
become a mess they're the parents of now
and that's probably in part why they're
having less children or at least talking
about family and children in a different
way well and there's there's also less
trust in the structure of the family
because the divorce rate has
proliferated and it's hard like there's
a woman in our
in the psychology department who's
Allison what's Allison's last name she's
going to hate me if she ever watches
this I can't think of it we'll post it
because you're gonna get it the second
week anyways she showed that if you if
you interfere with the maternal
relationship between rats and their pups
because rat children are called pups
that you can see the detrimental effects
of that disruption three generations
later Wow right yeah so you know you
disrupt those early bonds you disrupt
the familial structure that echoes it
takes a look it's like an oral tradition
in some sense you know because being a
good mother is not just something that
you're taught it's something that you
kind of have in your bones if you were
mothered properly like my father was an
excellent father especially when I was a
little kid I really spend a lot of time
with me
and I used to love it when he came home
and and like I have a natural affinity
for little kids and I do believe it's
it's in large part that's why it's
because I just know how to react with
them and it's me I do believe it's
because of the way that I was treated
when I was a little kid you disrupt that
it's like good lots of people don't
trust themselves his parents say because
they were hurt or they didn't have good
role models or they don't trust the
familial structure and so you know that
all that all makes people afraid yeah
all right so I only want to throw one
more piece into this and then and then I
want to focus on the book because we
should because you could do this for
five hours where do you think social
media and just the the phone and the
distraction look more than anything else
just the endless distractions we have
now where do you think that that factors
in to all of this that were constantly
split a thousand times over that the
family meal my parents always made sure
I mean basically five nights a week but
at least four nights a week we sat down
at the dinner table for a meal yeah
sometimes we'd be fighting the whole
time sometimes it would be great
whatever it was but we did you know is
an important but now everyone you go out
you know we're going out tonight
yan'er the amount of people that we're
gonna watch sit at a restaurant and
stare at their phone the whole time
while kids are right there or they give
them the kid an iPad and then yeah you
know yeah well I think first of all I
think that like human beings are social
eaters and it's a it's a species
character
and that's not that's really weird
social eating is really weird animals
don't share food like mother birds will
feed their chicks you know right but
animals as a rule don't share food like
if you're in a wolf pack and you bring
down a moose it's like the most dominant
wolves eat their fill and then you know
the less dominant wolves get to go in
there and pick up the scraps human
beings aren't like that like we have
this people like people who are alone
don't eat well generally speaking
they're not even hungry
we have this unbelievably deep need to
eat communally and it's a huge part of
socialization because well you got to
think that the regulation of eating is
the in some sense the only thing that
that could compare it with that would be
the regulation of anger and the
regulation of sex it's fundamental to
culture yeah sip like a civilized he
would be share the food properly be good
company pay attention learn to converse
be grateful for what you have to eat
those are basic basic they're not even
rules they're deeper than rules they're
patterns of behavior and you need that
so so not having that shared meal that's
a real catastrophe I think a third of
British families now don't even have a
dining room table it's really not good
and then with regards to the electronics
I don't think it's the content of the
electronics that's the problem I think
it's the fact of the electronics and I
think the danger to kids is they don't
engage in pretend play rough-and-tumble
and pretend play so even when I had kids
which is quite a while ago now you know
the electronic media wasn't so we didn't
have phone cell phones so but I'd often
take my kids to other couples who had
kids and they'd put all the kids in
front of the TV and have them watch a
movie it's like fair enough it was a
Disney movie maybe it was a good movie
there's nothing wrong with the movie but
there is something wrong with the fact
that the kids aren't wrestling that
they're not using their imagination to
figure out how to turn them like to turn
some weird object into a doll or a
firetruck or making a blanket for it and
playing out the roles of the family like
those things are crucially important we
know that the rough-and-tumble element
which is one of the things
fathers do with their kids like it's
really useful to play physically with
your kids
uh-huh because that's how they learn
what doesn't hurt and what does hurt you
know because I've played with little
boys who haven't had a father and
they're often awkward in their play they
don't know how to react to me first so
they're intimidated mm-hmm you know like
like a like a nota well socialized dog
my my friend has these Ridgebacks two of
them and they're really playful and he
wrestles with them all the time and one
of them came up to me today and I
whacked him on the side of the head and
in a playful way and immediately without
him he went over and started like
gnawing on his partner's head and
big-play about it just took that little
hint even for a dog to get it and so one
of the things you do with the father is
like you stretch your kid out and either
you know you tap them and and poke them
so that they they know what play is and
they know what what hurts and what
doesn't and you let them hit and wrestle
with you so they can figure out that
they shouldn't put their thumb in your
eye and it's kind of how they learn to
dance yeah to get coordinated and so
fathers really like to play with their
children and mothers are often somewhat
apprehensive about that because the guys
generally will play rougher with the
kids than not then the women will that's
a generalization for all of you who
think I'm being sexist but it'd be a
little doubt is pretty clear yeah but it
puts the kid in their body and gives
them a kind of confidence and then when
they're out on the playground and
they've got that play circuit already
activated the new kid will come up who's
like that and they can just make a
gesture at each other and bang they're
off playing yeah if the kids who don't
have that it's like other kids will come
up make a play gesture - nothing happens
they leave and go find a different kid
or they probably get the kick the crap
kicked out of it well there's that well
if they're really awkward you know so
here's all or they end up being the one
that does the kicking right yes
yeah yes exactly well in it so here's
that here's an example so imagine
there's three or four kids in a
playground together and they're there
it's recess and they're all zooming
their erasers around their helicopter
saying so the three of them have already
figured out they're playing helicopter
and an unpopular kid comes up and winds
a bit and says they wants to play
something else it's like that ain't
happenin
right that kids annoying he's an outcast
and that's permanent like if you're not
if you got haven't got that figured out
by the time you're four it's like good
luck to you right you're in trouble even
the popular kids have trouble with that
what's the little playgroup is formed so
what a popular kid will come and do is
he'll like sidle up to the playgroup
then you'll watch what's going on caught
you know calmly and patiently and coic
they're there in helicopter universe
right they got this whole pretend thing
going so then maybe he'll watch and
he'll take out his eraser or maybe a
pencil and watch the pattern and then
he'll say you know something like that
and if he does it just right then the
playgroup will open up and he gets to
come in and I've done that sort of thing
not with helicopters and races in
grocery stores like you know sometimes
I'll see a mother with a little child
and I'll start to play with the child
which is a you know touchy thing to do
in society but if you watch really
carefully you can see an opening you
know and if you if you know how to play
then you can you can take that opening
and everybody smiles and you know the
kid has fun and but even that though
that we've become so suspicious of each
other I know that's a little bit of a
sidebar there so someone like you who's
so in it all the time and that you care
about these things and put them into
practice but it must drive you crazy
well you know I went to Mexico a few
years ago and I had a really shocking
experience down there I was innocent
we went to this little resort that was
mostly Mexicans it was a you know like
it wasn't a high-end resort I don't
really like those sorts places but so
it's a place where Mexicans took their
families for vacation and so then we're
in the swimming pool and it's a sunny
afternoon and all these kids get in you
know and the next thing I know they're
all over there playing with me and the
mothers I'm looking at the mothers
thinking no no you know how's this gonna
go and they could give cared laughs yeah
for them that was just well of course
the kids are playing in the pool and you
know maybe they glanced at me and see
I'm throwing them up in the air or
whatever they didn't care but that would
just that's a no-go thing in our society
yeah it's really not good well it goes
to sorting a certain distrust that we
have for almost everything right now
yeah isn't it we have a distrust of our
political system for sure regardless of
where you fall politically there's a
major distrust in that there's a
trust now in Hollywood which i think is
fine there's even a distrust related to
to sports because they become so
politicized that everything is becoming
sort of distrust yeah yeah that's that's
that no I think I don't believe in the
idea of natural resources err okay fine
water yeah okay after that because it
takes human effort the idea of a natural
resource gets pretty screwy trust that's
a resource that's the fundamental thing
that makes cultures wealthy it's trust
and you know you got to distinguish
because between kinds of trust there is
naive trust that's the trust you have
when you're naive surprisingly when you
don't think that anyone is ever out to
hurt you and if you're naive and you get
hurt then you get traumatized in
proportion to the hurt and the naivety
not advisable you don't raise your
children to be naive mm-hmm in Sleeping
Beauty and Disney film yeah the king and
queen they're older they've been trying
to have a child they finally have one
Aurora like she's everything to them
they have a christening party for her
they don't invite the Evil Queen you
think well of course they don't who
invites the Evil Queen to the birthday
party it's like you got to invite the
Evil Queen to your kid's life because
otherwise they don't know that life is
hard and they don't know that they can
prevail through that and so what happens
to Sleeping Beauty is the first time
she's disappointed as soon as she grows
up soon she hit 16 pricks her finger a
little bit of blood she wants to be
unconscious mm-hmm because she can't
tolerate it she's been so protected she
can't tolerate life it's like so well so
you want to make sure that your kids are
that your kids are exposed to - to - to
experiences that push them and stretch
them as much as you possibly can
I guess that's part of the competence
thing we were talking about yeah you
love the Disney metaphor don't you that
that's a big one with yeah I mean I
think I know why you like just sort of
movie Jen metaphors in general but I
know your your Tokyo stories all the
Disney movies man they really nailed it
like I would say Beauty and the Beast
mm-hmm
they nailed that like they got the
archetypal structure dead-on
like that's the fundamental hero myth
women is like find a monster who wants
to be a good man and help him be a good
men don't find the you know
half-developed harmless thing find the
the guy that's he's a monster in through
it yeah exactly you know and and form a
relationship with him okay so fine and
that's a that's a scary thing to do and
a woman who hasn't had good experiences
with men will prefer a man who's well
the psychoanalytic idea would be
castrated essentially but rendered
harmless right well he won't hurt me
he's harmless it's like harmless is not
virtuous harmless is dangerous because
harmless people have no force in the
world and so they can't move forward
properly and so then they get resentful
and bitter and passive-aggressive and
they take things out on their
subordinates and you know that's what
that's about so for the woman it's like
you can step on him for a while in his
harmlessness but actually that's truly
corrosive for both of you it was
terrible and you know a woman who's
afraid of men can't distinguish
confidence from tyranny and so she sees
a competent man she thinks he's a tyrant
she hasn't separated those two things
out you know so it's like the guy who
marries someone and then turns and her
into his mother you know because he
can't tolerate the idea that his wife
could also be sexual you know so he D
sexualizes her over time and then
wonders why he's unhappy sexually when
he's 40 right you know cuz he can't
bridge the gap between mother and
mistress something like that so yeah the
Disney movies Beauty and the Beast
nailed it Little Mermaid dead-on
Sleeping Beauty dead-on
The Lion King I've done a lot of
analysis of it's a little more on the
edge because some of the archetypal
themes in it were put in consciously and
so they're not as they're not they're
more propagandistic in some sense so was
in pure storytelling that's right here
there was a goal yeah the goal wasn't
pure story and hollingers things because
everything sort of a goal now right
everything that seems to come out of
Hollywood is kind of it's a goal first
before the story yeah well now it just
doesn't work over
time I mean stories everything and a
story is something that you you can't
contrive it it has to manifest itself in
some sense now the story has an internal
logic and its own arc and if you're
aiming it at a moral statement that it's
not art its propaganda and it'll fall
flat frozen was a good example that was
propagandistic right from the end to the
beginning as far as I was concerned and
it was the right propaganda for the time
but but I know I know my niece loves it
but I don't want to watch it in 20 years
oh yeah I think where as they'll be
watching well The Little Mermaid for
beauty of the beast forever because
they're they're perfect Pinocchio's
pretty much perfect it gets a little
moralistic from time to time you know it
was done in the 30s it's like give them
a break isn't that though it's the
greatest thing sort of when you when you
get that piece of art that you know you
talked about the art before but a movie
whatever it is when you get that thing
that you're so in that wherever it ends
you're okay with did you happen to see
the last Wolverine movie
yeah I'm called Logan yeah it was so I
loved it I just thought it was great it
was gritty and dark and painful and and
so different than all these superior
movies and I in those last five minutes
when you knew it was coming to an end
I thought however they end this I can
accept it because I thought that's how
good it was it was giving me everything
I needed out of this like I was having
an actual emotional thing I thought
that's art right there
there's no they're not trying to
browbeat me with social justice or
browbeat me with anything else but
they're giving me something there I
thought it was just a nice feeling you
get so little of that in well pop
culture he's like the artist shouldn't
be able exactly to say what he or she is
doing if you can say what you're doing
you're not producing art art is well you
could say art bears the same
relationship to culture that the dream
does to mental stability you know your
your dream doesn't say what it's about
it just is you can interpret it and
that's helpful sometimes just like movie
criticism is helpful but the dream is
something that extends you beyond where
you already are that's why it isn't
verbal fought it's something else it's
like a pseudo part that's going out into
the unknown that's what art is and the
artists who
subsumes the artistic vision to the
ideological framework is putting the
cart before the horse it's actually a
sim night would say it's like the
ultimate and creative sins to do that
because you're harnessing the greater to
the lesser mmhmm like yeah you
understand things and you could tell a
story about what you understand it's
like no no you tell a story about what
you don't understand and then you pull
everyone into the story the story's an
exploration in that way and so you know
that's why I don't really think that
Iran qualifies as literature
I liked her books like I got into them
you know but but she she knew what she
was saying and you can tell because all
of her good characters are the same
character they have different bodies but
they're the same people and all the bad
people are the same people and they're
all voices for a political viewpoint and
you know she does weave into that heroic
plot and that redeems it to some degree
but she's not Dostoevsky because what
Dostoyevsky did and I mean he was the
greatest novelist that ever lived as far
as I'm concerned a head and shoulders
above anyone else I can think of he
didn't know the answer when he started
writing and so he'd have one character
stand for one set of principles and
ideas and another character stand for
another and he would develop those to
the fullest extent and put them in a
battlefield like a where where he made
both characters as powerful
representatives of those positions as he
possibly could and then he watched
outcome you know so and you're anything
you're taking along with that it's
amazing and that's what a good piece of
art does a good story good movie a good
painting for that matter it's more
complex with paintings but you know the
artist pulls you past where you are even
where he is
yeah artists can't tell you what the
hell they're up to you know they don't
know they can maybe guess but what
actually what they're doing when they
produce a piece of art is figuring out
what they're up to you know so and
that's when you know that they're
actually artists they're moving beyond
themselves yeah so well we could we I
somehow we just did an hour and but now
we have to do it
another hour on this and then we're
gonna still do some stuff all right but
since I know you have the fort you've
lasted with Rogan for a couple times
what at least three hours right yeah the
guy's a madman it's like going to be
it's like going to be interviewed by a
vacuum cleaner how would you describe
this if he's a vacuum cleaner it's good
this is good this is good this is good
you want the conversation to be intense
you know it's that's also a good sign
see that's it you're a gin guy by the
way there is gin behind you if it gets
to that point we'll see okay we'll see
maybe maybe was it thought that maybe
for the patrons yeah there you go
I really want to get to your boyo okay
let's do is you've made my job so I so
you sent me the PDF yesterday yeah I
read as much as I could in the last
couple hours but I thought the
simplicity with which you laid this out
was was really kind of brilliant because
basically as I said at the top you're
given people 12 sort of ways to stop
being pathetic I mean that's what it
really struck me as so I just wanted we
can hit everyone written from the point
of someone who tried to stop being
pathetic because I'm not saying look
you're pathetic and I got the answers
it's like no no it's like I got plenty
of work to do on myself you know so yeah
that's a key piece of this though right
for you personally that you're not
walking around going I've got I'm
perfect and you know we Texaco we spend
a couple hours we were talking about our
own shortcomings and what we're
struggling with and all that kind of
stuff and yeah that's a nipper to you
but you're open about it so few people
are open about it yeah well I'm like I'm
I live in some terror of making a
mistake knowing full well that I'm
perfectly capable of making that sort of
mistake you know and so and I'm I'm not
saying that I'm not saying or trying to
act out the idea that I've got what
would you say that I'm without error I
that's just
no we just won't go there
fair enough so this first one then again
there was a simplicity to this that I
love so the first one rule number one
stand up straight with your shoulders
back I love that one as the first one
because when I first started doing
stand-up I used to see a lot of guys
hunched over the mic yeah really bad
posture well-known comics and I always
remember thinking you gotta stand up
straight yeah well you've got good
posture just know I guess something
happened yeah
you do so you know my and my wife is a
massage therapist and she's very
physiologically aware so she's also
helped me with this sort of thing but we
watch people on the streets all the time
people in general now have very poor
posture yeah very bad for them but
that's that's got to be phone related -
right well yeah I think that's part of
it but I also think it's something our
culture doesn't attend to like you kind
of have to remind your kids to stand up
you know it takes a certain amount of
conscious effort but yeah in that
chapter I talked a lot about lobsters
which I'm going to I kind of have an
affinity for lobsters and because they
well the short story is that when a
lobster loses a fight because they're
fighting all the time for dominance
let's say in their hierarchies he kind
of crunches down so he looks smaller
when he wins the fight he stretches out
looks bigger and so he's signaling to
other lobsters the tally of his
victories and then say so if a lobster
has won a fight he's more likely to win
the next fight then you would calculate
from having a tally of all his previous
defeats and victories and if he loses a
fight then he's more likely to lose the
next fight so that's that that Mathieu
principle at work mm-hmm okay so you
think well so what so what does that
have to do with anything it's like okay
part of the kicker is well that lobster
runs on serotonin neurochemical and if
the lobster loses the serotonin levels
go down and if he wins the serotonin
levels go up and when the serotonin
levels go up he stretches out and he's a
confident lobster and one of the
consequences of that is if a lobster
loses a battle and you give him the
equivalent of antidepressants then he
stretches out and he'll go fight again
so antidepressants work on lobsters huh
right and you think well who cares it's
like no no you don't get it we diverged
from lobsters from an evolutionary
perspective 350 million years ago and
it's the same circuit it's absolutely
unbelievable and that shows you how deep
inside you how basic how primordial that
circuit is in you that sizing other
people up and looking at where they fit
in the hierarchy well with human society
it's more like hierarchies of confidence
than dominance per se
but and like if your serotonin levels
fall you get depressed you crunch
forward and and the whole everything
around you turns cloudy and black and
and then you're inviting more oppression
right and so you get into this bad loop
you know and so it's really important to
if you're trying to get your act
together it's really important to
stretch yourself out and and sit up
properly because it's it's part of the
psychophysiological loop that can start
you on the upward curve and so it's a
really important thing to take note of
and like if you've been bullied say when
you were a kid maybe you've moved and so
it's sort of irrelevant you're still
carrying that with you in the in the
hunched shoulders and then you can't
breathe properly and your voice isn't
right and you invite more bullying
because the predator types are always
looking for people who who look like
they can be intimidated and who make a
nice fuss if they are you know like a
nice gratifying
they'll make nice gratifying sounds of
suffering if you do that right that's
what a bully really wants and so that's
what the first chapter is about it's
like it's about it
hierarchy boat and it's a critique in
some sense also of the idea of the
patriarchy I know because the patriarchy
is this dominant oppressive hierarchy
that everyone's embedded in and you know
the social constructionist social
justice warrior postmodernist types
think about that as a social
construction it's like how about no
that's just wrong lobsters have
hierarchies that's a third of a billion
years ago okay that's not a social
construction it's part of being itself
and if you only see a hierarchy as power
and tyranny then you're looking at the
world wrong like it's true that
hierarchies can be tyrannical and
dominant mm-hmm and and a degenerated
hierarchy is nothing but tyranny but in
a functional society that the hierarchy
is actually the structure of the society
and you're actually protected within it
well then how you relate to that
hierarchy is very important but that's
part of personal development that's
parts down and up right you know and
then people in the hierarchy think oh
well you're someone who could do good
things for the hierarchy
let's promote you yeah you know like men
don't struggle for power that isn't what
men do not if they're civilized they
size each other up and elect the
competent to lead them and they do that
at every level of society like I tell a
story in their boat might be later in
another chapter it doesn't matter I
worked in a rail crew and in
Saskatchewan they're rough guys like a
lot of them had been in prison you know
and when you first came onto the rail
crew you got a stupid nickname and
people teased you and I remember this
one kid called lunch bucket that was his
nickname because he came to the rail
crew with a lunch bucket that looked
like his mom had packed it that was a
bad idea
you bring your damn lunch and kind of us
you know ratty paper bag don't make too
big a thing out and it's dirty and
smelly it's like you're not pronouncing
your status we have a Barbie blood prize
exactly yes yeah so they named a lunch
bucket which he wasn't very happy about
yeah well that was a mistake he should
have taken it with a smile and then he
was always peevish and irritable and if
he asked him to do something he whined
and so like this was soon after I joined
the Royal rail crew well soon there's
about 60 men on this crew it stretched
out about a quarter of a mile down the
tracks soon anonymous harasses were
throwing pebbles at him during work we
had hard out so on so the game was let's
see if we can hit that lunch bucket in
the in the hardhat with a pebble yeah
well because you don't know where it's
coming from
yeah and then that was purposeful
because he didn't couldn't take a joke
it's like well let's see if he can take
this joke
clunk and everybody go No and then it
just got more and more peevish and the
pebbles got bigger and bigger and you
know week later lunch bucket was gone
and having not learned anything from the
experience but you know the men were
testing him out it's like can you take a
joke can you can you can you be useful
can you at least be amusing if I can
these are something worthwhile about you
it's like no it's like okay well then
you're out of here because you never
know when we actually might need to
depend on you it's so interesting to me
because it fits fully within what you
were saying about why it's important to
for a father to play with a kid or why
sibling my brother and I used to beat
the living crap out of each other
win sometimes I'd win sometimes but we
learned something there and that's what
yeah you I think you said it's like
learning how to dance and yeah but I
like that you started this with
something physical because all of us can
do this everyone watching this today
that's struggling with whatever they
extraordinaire can just work on that
yeah you know whoever's watching this
that is God's best given posture ever
can still work on that if you happen to
be hunched forward you know
weightlifting is really good for that
because you strengthen out your back
muscles and it'll pull your shoulders
back and you want that and it's really
important as you get older because you
look at old people you know and if
they're a stoop they start to calcify
that way and then they start to bend
down and like you know you don't want to
be in that situation when you're 40 yeah
you know maybe you want to be enough you
don't ever you don't ever
yeah maybe 90 you know but not 40 and
certainly not 20 and so you know you
need to do a postural analysis and/or
have someone take a look at you and say
well you know yeah you're kind of
hunched forward and they're gonna be
conscious about it you gotta pull back a
lot open up it's also kind of a I think
part of the reason it signifies
dominance is because like this is a
protective Crouch right and it's to stop
animals to jump on your back from
getting out your soft part so it's it's
it's instinctual its protective right so
this basically says I'm open to the
world
right but what it also says is I can
handle being open to the world so it
signifies competence and confidence yeah
it's interesting because it's also a
sort of vulnerable position anyway and
in you know yoga or certain other
stretching things Feldenkrais and things
like that you would work on this yeah
you would also with the mansplaining
people will not be happy when they know
no they're gonna see us doing this
they're not gonna be happy about that
well the thing about competence is
acceptance of vulnerability right that's
that's what competence is it's that's a
deep idea yeah I mean the deepest
Christian idea for example is that you
should accept the vulnerability of being
that's the acceptance of the crucifixion
essentially it's like you know you're at
the X where all the suffering takes
place you're gonna whine about that you
know and get resentful and bitter about
it because there's reason to like let's
make no mistake about it or are you
gonna say bring it on I can handle it no
matter what it is well maybe maybe you
can't do that but that's what you're
aiming for
you're Aemon you're aiming out being
able to handle it no matter what it is
and to do that voluntarily and the idea
is that if you can do that you will
transcend the tragedy and it's like well
could that be true well most people
admire tough competent people so you
know it's at least a little bit true
mm-hmm you know you admire the
courageous so well how courageous can
you get that's the question how
courageous can you get well you practice
and see and it makes you want to be
better I'll tell you I didn't tell you
this two weeks ago but when we did that
event which was spectacular at the end
when all the kids were coming up to say
hi to us there's a line for the two of
us your line did have more people they
were planning on mine too but I actually
felt after truly I'd was like I have to
be better now this means I have to be
better and I thought I felt great about
it like I actually didn't feel jealous
of you or whatever I was like oh he
brought it and it's like I should bring
it to so that well that's competition is
is a wonderful thing it is it is it well
the thing is is that and that's the
opposite of while in the story of Cain
and Abel Cain kills Abel because he
can't stand the fact that he's better
than him that's really it it's said he
knows he's better than him there's no
doubt about that and and so Abel is
actually his ideal because that's what
it means to see someone who's better
than you get jealous of that you're
getting jealous of your own ideal well
that's a very bad idea it's like what
you should do is you should watch and
you should think well there's something
going on there that I haven't quite got
and maybe if I watch I could figure it
out it's like it's an opportunity right
now it doesn't mean you got to take that
guy down and in this case kill him great
you got to work on yourself well that's
yeah well it's an opportunity even to do
that you know yeah and you also have to
remember too that people have their
times and you know things oscillate and
sometimes you meet someone who's kind of
at a pinnacle in their life in some
sense and you're not that doesn't mean
it's always gonna stay that way that's
the other thing is like even very
successful people have their while they
get sick and die you know we've got this
fundamental limitation that equalizes us
in some sense and that's also very much
worth worth knowing you know it's like
you don't know when you see someone
successful you don't know
the full tragedy of their being and so
there's another chapter there in the
dark yeah I called compare yourself to
who you were yesterday and not to who's
someone else is today on that note why
don't we pause for literally we'll pause
for one minute yeah we'll look at the
gin at least and then and then we'll be
alright so we're gonna take literally
one minute guys give me 60 seconds and
then war with Jordan Peterson just say
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright guys I think that was maybe 67
seconds there must be a rule about that
if you say you're going away for 60
seconds yeah don't don't don't go away
there's two guys you can heal and ask me
I think that's rule number nine yeah
rule number two treat yourself like
someone you are responsible for helping
I mean it's it seems pretty clear to me
what this means
yeah well that's an investigation into
why people don't treat themselves well
and the thing is is that you know human
beings are self conscious and we know
about our limitations and we know about
our weaknesses and so we can have
contempt for human beings in general
because you know we're just flawed and
breakable and all of that and but we
know ourselves better than we know
everyone else and so unless you're
narcissistic and some people are then
you have a very acute sense of how
you're not up to scratch and in on many
of the dimensions along which you could
be evaluated even by yourself and so
that leads naturally to a sort of
contempt self contemptuous attitude and
you can see that one of the stories I
talk about is that people are more
likely to give prescription medication
to their pets than to take them
themselves right right you know so what
I'm in the United States because we're
pretty over medicated here even in the
United States well people will get the
prescriptions but they won't take the
pills
anyways that the idea there is it's it's
sort of a variation that I learned from
Carl Jung on treat other people as it as
you would like to be treated it's you
reverse that it's like imagine someone
that you treat well that you love then
try to treat yourself that way you got
to detach from yourself a bit you got to
think okay well I'm a person among other
people and I deserve at least as much
respect as a person among other people
and I should be trying to help myself
across time and instead of being self
contemptuous and self destructive I need
to take care of myself as if I'm
potentially valuable and to lay out my
life that way and so that's what that's
that chapter is about and it's it it's
hard for
you know they don't take care of
themselves as well as they should and I
don't mean you know take care of
yourself I mean that is what I mean it's
like it's not a moralistic attack it's
like it's an encouragement to give
yourself a bit of the benefit of the
doubt and and treat yourself as if you
have some intrinsic value yes so how
much of that would you say is is
psychological just being okay with the
mistakes you're gonna make and all of
that as opposed to just fit like treat
yourself meaning dress okay yeah well
bandmaster and all that's part of it
yeah it isn't clear where your your
borders actually are you know it means
take care of your room take care of your
things like have some respect for
yourself as a as a well I would say in
some sense as a miraculous being because
that is actually what you are but you
know that that sort of borders on the
New Age which I don't I'm not very happy
about that but still the case it's like
you are there is a lot of potential
within you and there's many things that
you can do and you're necessary you're
necessary more than you think to the
unfolding of things like if you make a
bunch of bad decisions things get worse
not just for you like things get worse
and maybe way worse like I don't know
what mistakes tell ins mother made you
know and she brought II didn't
necessarily think they were that
important but it turned out they were
pretty important mm-hmm you don't know
how your actions echo and so it matters
what you do and and so part of what you
do is you want to treat yourself as if
what you do matters and so you want to
have some respect for yourself and some
fear of yourself that's also that and so
that's what that chapters about yeah
number three rule number three make
friends with people who want the best
for you ah this is a particularly
interesting one these days I think
because we connect with people all over
the world that we don't meet face to
face you know there's kind of rule of
thumb for that which is if you have a
friend and you tell them bad news
they're actually sad and you can tell
them they will listen you know they'll
listen they'll take the damn pain and
they won't tell you about some worst
thing that happened to them defensively
say or they won't secretly
happy that you got knocked off your
pedestal you know they'll listen and
then the other thing is is if you have a
friend and something good happens to you
they're happy
yeah well that's the thing is you like
you know if you're trying to quit
smoking and your friends are often you
cigarettes that's like look there's a
joke you can make a joke about that and
if it's a joke it's fine but often those
sorts of jokes aren't jokes right I'm
smoking you're smoking you're quitting
you think you're better than me it's
like can I get you to smoke and then I
don't have to be like embarrassed that
I'm not able to do it or you're an
alcoholic can I think yeah you know who
cares about the fact that you've screwed
up your third marriage it's like have
another drink ha ha ha it's like no it's
and the other thing you know people
don't exactly understand that they it's
okay morally to choose people that are
trying to help you be better and to shy
away from people who are going to drag
you down so right this image always
comes to mind for me you know if you're
a lifeguard and you want to rescue
someone who's drowning the way you swim
up to them is like this with your foot
out and the reason is well maybe they're
panicking and to drown people is not an
improvement over one so you know you you
you don't have though you're not morally
obliged to go down with someone else's
ship now you think that's pretty harsh
and pretty rude you can't abandon a
friend in need that's not what I'm
saying
I'm saying that it is appropriate for
you to look at your social surround
mm-hmm and to make decisions if you have
a person who's hurting you and who won't
quit and who's pulling you down it's
like you don't have to that is not
necessary you are not obligated to do
that you go with people that are trying
to elevate you you know what I think I
thought this this chapter was
particularly powerful is because I get
so much email and I think one of the
questions we got of Clemson was related
to this that so many of the people who
are waking up to the nonsense of
post-modernism and all that they're
losing friends you know I mean they're
losing their old friends who view that
thing as this religion that you must
adhere to but what I found even though I
did lose a lot of friends over the last
couple years of
from my old life even though I'm the
same me that I always was is that I've
gained newer richer friends including
the guy sitting right across from me
right now and that is a powerful thing
you can shed people - yes while you
actually are obligated to it's like you
are not obligated to associate with
people who are making your life worse or
who even more and I would say this more
more profoundly in some sense you are
obligated not to associate with people
who are trying to damage the structure
of being your being
so the family being social being all of
that it's like no wrong move away and
you think well you know that's cruel
it's like it's not cruel you're sending
a message this sort of behaviors not to
be tolerated
plus if you make a success out of
yourself let's say that you develop your
character well then you're in your
you're a example and at some point maybe
that's what that person is gonna need is
an example you know maybe they'll hit
bottom and think oh my god I'm not on
the right path it's like there's an
example I could follow so and you can't
justify it by compassion because often
now it's an excuse - it's like I'm I'm
hanging around with my drug addict
alcoholic friends because I want to help
them it's like really exact right maybe
probably not though you know how to st.
probably maybe you are yeah but it's
unlikely number four compare yourself to
someone who you were yesterday not to
someone else not to let's start that oh
yeah I'm sorry because I want to get it
right compare yourself to who you were
yesterday not to who someone else is
today yeah well you got to improve right
and so and you might think well I'm a
real fixer-upper and I'm really
embarrassed about that because there's
50 things wrong with being like look at
that guy and so now I feel all terrible
because of the comparison and all of
that and first of all it's unfair
because especially by the time you're
about 30 when you're 17 you're like
every other 17 year old and so that kind
of social comparison is more appropriate
by the time you're about 30 your life
has become quite idiosyncratic you know
like let's say your life has eight
dimensions family friends intimate
relationships
health you know you can kind of lay them
out your individually positioned and all
those dimensions your life isn't like
anyone elses life and so you see someone
who's doing better than you it's like
you're only seeing one dimension at one
slice of time so it's not reasonable you
know what you don't have the whole
picture you know so and then you you get
down on yourself and and take the spirit
out of yourself and you get bitter and
resentful it's like that there's nothing
good about that yeah so so but you do
need to improve because there's more to
you that there's not as much of you as
there should be so what's the comparison
well that's easy you just say okay well
here here's my position in time in space
right now here's my virtues and faults
it's like I can be a little bit better
tomorrow in some minor way well that's
the right comparison because you are
very much like you you know you know
what I mean everything is the same about
you yeah and so it's the perfect
comparison and then you get a trajectory
going it's like well like obviously I'm
not perfect but I'm slightly less
terrible than I was yesterday
man you keep that up for five years and
you're wherever you should be that isn't
where someone else should be right
because you really are an individual
there's an interesting element of this
on a biblical note that I think you hit
sometimes which is sort of don't pray to
false gods because it's like it's sort
of like well the guy that you're looking
at that you think has everything yeah
you have no idea yeah right and we see
that now with all these people crumbling
in Hollywood that are worshipped by so
many people who have done all sorts of
terrible things or whatever it is yeah
well you just don't have insight into
the tragedy of someone else's life you
know when you might think well he's rich
and successful it's like yeah but you
just don't know you don't know what his
relationship is with his wife or his
children you know you don't know that
he's going through two divorces and his
daughter will talk to him and one of his
kids is schizophrenic and like most
people's lives are pretty nicely
saturated with tragedy you know and with
a certain degree of malevolence and you
might think well I'd trade places with
him in a minute
and I'm also not saying that some people
don't have it really rough it's like
look man some people have it rough yeah
that's not the point it's not the point
the point is you should be better than
you are but it's not because you're
than other people it's because you're
not everything you should be and so you
go to pick the comparison rate and then
that's also ennobling it's like an
instantly hopeful there is absolutely no
doubt that you can be slightly better
tomorrow than you are today and then
because of the Pareto principle that you
know that that that movement towards the
good increases exponentially that
trajectory can just take you out of hell
very very rapidly and so you know
there's nothing but good about that
yeah just quick sidebar before we get to
number five so you mentioned sort of 17
we're all sort of at that same you can't
have that much differentiation between
three but thirty it's a little more
calcified do you think there's an a
cutoff age I don't mean exactly a number
like you're gonna say 56 but do you
think that there's a point and then
there was a question asked at Clemson
where somebody said to you you know
you've really hoped my 60 year old
father who had all this stuff going
wrong in his life he was started
listening to you and he said he's I
think she said he's in the best place
he's ever been I think but do you think
that there's a cutoff age where just
physiologically you can't quite well I
think a lot harder did you get more who
you are as you get older you know so
there's not the ratio of actuality to
potential starts to shift but but it
doesn't change the underlying simple
truth which is there is definitely
something that you can do today that
will make you slightly better for the
next day always always no lets okay not
always you're 85 right you have
Alzheimers you know you're done
sometimes you're done but most of the
time you're not and most of the time
there's something within your grasp that
you could put right and see that's the
fundamental issue it's like life is
tragic it's full of suffering and it's
full of malevolence there's no doubt
about that and it's it's brutal and it's
more brutal than you can even imagine in
some ways or willing to imagine but
there's something you could put right
and we don't know what would happen if
you put everything you could right if
you put it right and then we don't know
what would happen if everyone did that
but you can be certain that it would be
less tragic and less malevolent and so
like you don't have anything better to
do that right like get-get get out it
get crashing all right number five do
not let your children do anything that
makes you dislike them this has sort of
been a few line to at least the
beginning part of our yeah well the
first thing is it's the monster thing
like the beauty of beast thing you are
not a good guy and you will take revenge
on your children if they misbehave you
think oh no I like my children it's like
other people might not like them maybe
they don't behave very well you know and
you think you like them because you're a
saint but you're not and you will take
revenge on those children if they do
things that make you dislike them so
you're in the grocery store and you've
got a four year old and the four year
old is pretty smart checking you out all
the time
you're like nope I'm you and prodding
you and seeing what's there because
that's what little kids do they're not
that verbal so they're there they're
like they they have you could compare
their behavior in some ways to pack
animals like dogs which is why they like
dogs and get along with dogs they
understand each other you know and so
they're testing you out so they have a
temper tantrum in the store and you
don't know what to do about it what you
do your kid has a temper tantrum in the
store you pick up the child you go
outside with them you stand them up
somewhere and just let them have it let
them have the temper tantrum it's like
they'll get sick of it soon enough go
somewhere boring and dull say well have
a doorman then the kids done you say
we're gonna stand right here till you
decide that you're gonna behave the
child knows what that means it's like
you're gonna behave or we're just gonna
stand here it's like fine okay you don't
do that the child has a temper tantrum
it's the third one you know you're
embarrassed you're turning red
everyone's sweating everyone's looking
at you like you're a horrible parent
it's like really unpleasant think oh I
love my child I like my child it's like
no you don't that's a lie
you go home the kids forgotten all about
it you know they go in their room they
make a little drawing they're all
thrilled they come out and show it to
you and maybe they did a really good job
you know maybe they're even a little
guilty about having the damn tantrum but
you man you're not happy and you think
yeah that's nice and you go back to
whatever useless thing you're doing and
you think
got that little bastard and you think no
I wouldn't think that it's like yeah
wrong you would wrong not only would you
think it you would act it out and if you
don't think that that's true then you
don't know yourself very well and so you
got to think that little kid is little
and powerless well not as powerless as
you might think but fundamentally you
got the upper hand and you've got the
proclivity for tyranny deeply rooted in
you and so you better be real careful
around that child i I used to tell my
kids you know when I was not in a good
mood say it like it would be better if
you were in your room and they didn't
mind they knew what it meant you know
they were very young they could
understand that it's like oh you're a
fine kid you know pat pat pat I'm not in
a good mood things are likely to be
unpleasant why don't you just go play in
your room for a while Slyke way they
went they knew how to play in their room
you know cuz I didn't want them being
around me when I wasn't being gonna be a
good guy yeah and so in kids they they
know they can handle that man they can't
handle lies they can handle that sort of
truth no problem and so like I both my
wife and I we were very careful it's
like when we're starting to not be happy
with the kids with one kid or the other
it was time to have a chat and figure
out what it was that had gone off the
rails and how we were gonna fix it so
that we were like thrilled to have that
kid around and that's the thing about
kids is you can be thrilled to have them
around not always you're tired you're
hungover like you've had a bad day the
kids cranky like I'm not saying this is
utopia it's not that's not the point but
the point is though you you can manage
your relationship with your kids and you
can have an honest relationship with
them and then it will be the best
relationship with anybody you've ever
had in your life and I can say that with
some certainty because like I had a
rough time with my daughter because she
was very very very ill for a long time
it was really bad for like seven years
it's still touch-and-go but it was she
was in excruciating agony for two
straight years which I can't believe she
even did it because like three hours of
pain that's intense
that's rough two years it's like maybe
you don't get through that you know
mm-hmm but we had a good relationship
dur and thank God if our
we hadn't been well put together by that
point it would have been it would have
taken tragedy and turned it into hell
and so we had a rough time for those
years and still it was good you know
that's an something because well she
lost her hip and her ankle during that
period they were both replaced when she
was 16 and so she was walking around on
two broken legs for two years it was
brutal but but I felt like my son for
example during that period of time and
like hats off to him he was only 14 you
know when he wanted to be out with all
his friends he stuck around he supported
her he never complained about it he
never complained about the fact that he
didn't get the attention he should have
got he was there like a bloody Rock and
my sister relied on him a lot loves him
to death
partly because of that it's like that
was a good thing and it was because of
that foundation that we had laid you
know and we wouldn't have gone through
that with its powerful I mean I could
even see it in your face like the the
just a slight change as you talk about
it because it's real it was brutal man
like one night I went down to talk to
her and like the pain had driven her
past the edges of her sanity I could see
that she was gonna crack and we were
looking all over the world to find
somewhere to get her ankle replaced fast
you know because it degenerated very
quickly and the surgeon that we had been
talking to wanted to fuse it and we
weren't into that we wanted to get a
replacement but they're rare and anyways
I won't bore you with all the details
but yeah it was it was brutal and in
those situations if your family is
fractured it's like you don't have the
extra energy to deal with the fracturing
you know you got to have had your ship
in order you know when you're in stormy
seas it's almost like when you know it's
like when Grandma dies and then the
family just goes crazy after that or
that like it all starts coming out when
it's not a tragedy well that's it that's
how you see that that's a great example
you see that lauda to death that no my
my my wife's mother died of essentially
Alzheimer's it was pre frontal temporal
dementia and she got it pretty young and
degenerated over about 15 years and her
husband who's her in the extroverted
party type guy I have a lot of respect
for him I like him a lot but he wasn't
the sort of stay home and tend to the
needy type you know
but when his wife got sick man he took
care of her it was it was unbelievable I
just cannot believe how good he was at
how patient and her family just pulled
together and on her deathbed to like her
sister's a palliative care nurse and
their other sisters a pharmacist they've
had some contact with the rough parts of
life you know I was out there her
deathbed and like the family was
together and one of the things that was
so interesting about that was that they
lost their mother and like that's
horrible and it's a horrible way to die
but it's so interesting because the
bonds between them the the sibling bonds
and the bonds with the kids and the
father were tightened a lot after that
and so in some sense although there was
something taken away and it wasn't
trivial and I'm not being a Pollyanna
about this they strengthened their damn
family and we spent more time with them
and we get along better and it's like
there was a compensation for it and so
you think well what happens if you act
nobly through a tragedy well first of
all it's better than the not doing it
right but then you also increase the
probability that whatever good might
come out of it is going to come out of
it so you know you can take a tragic
situation and tragedy isn't hell but you
can make tragedy into hell and then it's
hell and no one can stand out yeah it's
good stuff
rule number six set your house in
perfect order before you criticize the
world oh that's a rough one now it's
about us that's about a mass murderer
and about mass murderers yeah so I
didn't I didn't get this far because as
I said I just got this well there's
plenty of things to criticize about
being it's tragic
and there's malevolence that's basically
the issue and you can complain about
that but the thing is if you complain
about that if you adopt that attitude
which is sort of an anti being attitude
you go places that if you knew you were
going you probably wouldn't want to go
it's the places where like the kids that
showed up Columbine went those are bad
places
like you were if you read the writings
of the Columbine High School kids and
you really read them mm-hmm
if they don't make the hairs that stand
up in the back your neck you are not
paying attention like he they one kid
wrote things I cannot believe that
people could write and I've exposed
myself to a lot of crazy things that
people have done and said you just can't
understand it it's it's it's uncanny
you know well that's where you end up if
you're if you get bitter it's like well
what can you do about that well the
world is harsh it's like should you
criticize it it's like not until you put
yourself together you got to bring
everything you can to bear on the
problem before you have any right to
stand in judgment about being itself and
that's what these mass murderers do
that's what they're doing that's what
they're acting out they're saying well
I'm looking out in the world I don't
like people they're full of flaws they
act badly there are cancer on the face
of the planet it'd be better if they
didn't exist at all so I don't like
being it's too full of suffering and and
an evil I'm the judge of this it's like
I'm gonna make my goddamn case I'm gonna
take them out and then it's more than
that it's like I'm gonna take them out
and I'm gonna do it with innocence first
because that's the thing you got to get
about the mass murderer types is like
they're not hunting down the guilty
that's too obvious right they're hunting
down the innocent that's the best
protest that's why the guy showed up the
elementary school in Connecticut it's
like why do you shoot kids well think
about it well I don't want to think
about it well that's for sure you bloody
well don't want to think about it
but you better think about it it's like
well that's where you go when you take
that criticism of being approached it's
like you don't get to do that no unless
you want to end up there it's bad so
what do you do instead it's like okay
stop doing stupid things stop lying stop
making things worse
stop making yourself weak you know
everyone does that they know it you know
and I'm not saying follow the rules I'm
not saying that I'm saying even in a day
you'll see that you have choices in
front of you and sometimes you don't
know what to do okay you're ignorant
maybe you make a mistake
whatever
that's just ignorance malevolence is
when you know what you shouldn't do mm
and you do it anyways
and people do that all the time and
that's arrogance that's I'll get away
with it it's okay
it's deceit because you're lying to
yourself about whether you should do
this or not you know you shouldn't write
you know and then it's resentment
because well it's like I'm gonna do this
bad thing because that'll teach the
people or whatever that'll teach God to
treat me this way it's like that's
that's the that's the terrible Trinity
deceit arrogance resentment it's like
chase those out of your life
rule number seven pursue what is
meaningful not is not what is expedient
yeah well that meaning is what you have
to to buttress yourself against the
tragedy of life it's like engagement
we're having an engaging conversation
you know we'll walk away from this and
hopefully the people who are watching
they'll walk when they'll think that was
worthwhile it's like okay think about
what that means it means that despite
the fact that you're a fragile damaged
mortal creature you found something to
do that announced itself as worthwhile
mm-hmm
that's meaning it's an instinct like
it's not it's a deep deep instinct it's
it's maybe the deepest instinct it's
like a form of vision except it's not a
it's not like an embodied set it's not a
specified sense meaning tells you when
you're in the right place and the right
place is between chaos and order and
those are real places your hemispheres
like your right hemisphere is roughly
evolved let's say to deal with things
you don't understand that's chaos and
your left is there to deal with things
you do understand it you can't just stay
with the things you do understand
because you already understand them and
you can't just stay with what you don't
understand because then you're lost yeah
well you need to be in the middle of
those two and you can tell when you're
in the middle because everything lines
up and you you feel engaged and that
what you're doing is meaningful it's
like that's what you pursue expedience
is you do the thing that gets you off
the hook the fastest right now well that
you play that game
across time it doesn't work it sends you
down because you're sacrificing the
future for the present meaning doesn't
do that meaning says I'm here where I
should be
and you can't tell why it's just that
everything is right and you you get this
physiological sense right place right
time right conversation you know and
that's usually a conversation where
you're both trying to expand the way
that you look at the world well so you
follow this meaningful path that's your
buttress against the tragedy that
produces resentment and malevolence his
meaning is the antidote to that and
that's the fundamental religious truth
and it's really true that's the thing
that's so life is suffering that's true
there's malevolence that's true meaning
is the antidote to that yes and it's not
it's not some kind of fragile
epiphenomena it's the deepest thing so
and people need to know that it's so
important to know that and there's a
feeling associated with the to write a
physiological feeling because as you're
saying that I feel that I mean I I'm
sort of lucky as an interviewer I
sometimes I interview people and I don't
get that but I find out in the best
interviews that I do and even in
portions that we've done here when I
really am in it with somebody and and I
can see that they they know what they're
talking about they believe what they're
talking and all that I feel sort of
differently I actually feel oh you know
differently even even just looking at
you not this specific second but there
are moments where it's almost like it's
not blurry or something but like I look
colors are a little sad yeah yeah
absolutely but you can actually feel
something powerful and it's interesting
because for me the only reason I do this
show is because I wanted something like
this to be and I didn't see it you know
like I was like where where are people
having meaningful conversations where
are people expounding and ideas and all
that I started doing it and now people
come up to me and say man that what
you're doing has meaning to me right so
that that's a pretty powerful thing
right there yeah well then people say
well meaning isn't real it's like no
that's wrong
it's actually the most real thing it
might even be more real than suffering
and evil it's possible and they're like
I think about about this technically you
know I'm this isn't
had a physical assumption that I'm
making and you do feel it it's you feel
it in your body it's not just a a mental
thing it's not an idea
it's a place it's a place because we're
in time and space right and a place is
it is a place you know three dimensions
of space but it's also a time and when
the place and the time are set up
properly you're in the right place and
your brain is telling you that your
being is telling you that yeah you got
it right right you know it's gonna fall
apart cuz you're not gonna be there all
the time right you daughter get that
pretty quick often right that's just
part of life yeah well you say you know
you go see a great movie
it's like hey you're in the right place
at the right time and if you're engaged
you're completely engaged in it it's
because it's because it's there's no
other way to put it
you're in the right place at the right
time and the meaning is the signal of
that and so the purpose of profound
religious contemplation in some sense in
the deepest sense the profound
philosophical contemplation is to learn
how to be in the right place at the
right time all the time now you can't
because you're not perfect but you can
be there a lot more than you are and you
can actually practice it and you
practice it by paying attention you
think you watch yourself during the day
like you don't know who you are or what
you're doing and you notice oh yeah
right there I was listening to that
piece of music or as having that
conversation or as doing this piece of
work then I was there for like 10
minutes okay why I was doing something
right I don't know what it is I want to
or I wasn't doing something wrong you
know and so I got this little
illuminated moment it's like okay I need
to figure out how to be there more often
so there's this line from the Gospel of
Thomas which was discovered in like 1957
and it says the kingdom of God is spread
out before the eyes of man but men do
not see it that's basically it and
that's kind of what it's referring to
it's like there are times when you're in
the right place at the right time and
then you're where you should be and you
you don't notice that you don't say oh
look wow there's something about this
this is right I gotta figure out how to
do this more right because that sucks
you out of it immediately
if you could do that right right well
that's also partly why it's hard and and
you're not really trained to notice that
because it isn't something we ever
talked about it's like you're in the
right place at the right time okay why
what did i do right what did I do I need
to do more of that so maybe it's only
half an hour a week when you first start
noticing and then maybe with three
months of practice you can get it up to
like an hour a day and then maybe you
can get it up to four hours a day and
god only knows where you could get it if
you if you keep practicing you know you
can you can be there we don't know what
the opéra limit of that is yeah you know
if you're in a crowd where the music is
really kicking in the band is you know
the bound now and then you'll get a band
and they just they're on the same
wavelength that's just something else
and you can feel it snap in so a concert
will go from good to great and all of
the audience is participating as well
right they're all moving to the same
rhythm and you get this intense feeling
that everything is lined up and is in
the right place it's like yes yes that's
why people go to concerts because they
get that they get the chance to have
that happen and it's sort of like this
it's this vision of how life could be
you know and then you know you go home
and things fragment again but at least
for a minute everything came into
Lineman harmoniously and that's what
you're trying to do is to get every
level of being harmoniously lined up
like music like a symphony that's what
that's why people like symphonies
because everything lines up and then
you're there you know so that's what
that's what you want to aim at yeah if I
can take it to a basketball metaphor I
mean this is what when players talk
about being in the zone when you're
Stephanie you're just throwing it up and
and you're not even thinking and it's
going in and you don't even realize it
and often when they talk about it after
that you know they won't even realize
that wow that was a seven minute stretch
they think of it as a thirty second
little wing that's right time goes away
yes well that's the Dow that the Dow is
talked about that's the zone that's the
line between chaos and order and to be
there is to be in the right place that's
why people watch sports but part of its
the competition in the victory and
that's all fine but this the serious
thing is those moments when you're in
the zone with the players because
they're acting out being in the zone and
everyone loves that and the Quidditch
game
in Harry Potter there's two games going
on at the same time there's the ordinary
game which is just a game and there's
the seeker game and the seeker is going
after this golden thing that flickers in
front of them and if they get that thing
then not they win and the team wins well
she got it exactly right I guess I that
little thing that snitched yeah everyone
is chasing is actually an ancient
alchemical symbol for the union of chaos
and aura
I don't know how in the world she
figured that out it's called the round
chaos it's unbelievably obscure if you
look it up on Google I think the only
reference to the round chaos is from my
website I learned it from reading young
I don't know how she figured it out Wow
but so the seeker is seeking this thing
that glimmers in front of them right and
moves everywhere right that's mercury
that winged messenger of the gods right
and so you're chasing that now and then
you get it and everyone wins so yeah
that's that's meaning yes that is
meaning rule number eight tell the truth
or at least don't lie this has been a
sort of theme of everything we've been
talking about it's it's hard why because
you have to know the truth and that's
hard but you can know when you're lying
you'd sometimes you don't know because
what the hell do you know but sometimes
you know mm-hmm and you can feel that
that's a disjunction of meaning so
you'll know you see this often with
people who are very socially awkward you
know they'll say something that's sort
of grandiose and it really falls flat
and everyone's a bit embarrassed
including them it's like they've if they
were paying attention they would notice
that that disunited them and made them
weak and then they wouldn't say it and
so that's that's the thing about not
lying is that lies make you weak and you
can feel it it's it's the antithesis of
meaning I would say because meaning is
associated with the truth so if you're
if you're lying you're you're at the
opposite pole of that that's the deceit
part and it makes you weak you think
well I'll lie and I'll get away with it
it's like no you won't you you cannot
get away with warping the structure of
being well that's why the arrogance
comes in it's like well I can lie and
get away with it it's like I see here's
your theory
there's all this reality around you that
you don't comprehend at all and there's
not that much of you there's a lot of it
mm-hmm and you're gonna do something
that isn't in harmony with that and it's
gonna work
that's your theory Hansen that's some
serious nurses well yeah we all do that
to some degree or at least at some point
in our lives right
you all think we can manage everything
well it's part of it you can't you can
get away with it for a shorter period of
time right that so you think well I've
got away with it so far it's like yeah
it's like that funny line in The
Simpsons Bart comes up to Homer and says
dad this is the worst day of my life and
Homer says yeah the worst day of your
life so far your life so far yeah just
it's that show man now and then they
nailed that was one of them those 10
years I mean but don't like season four
and and twelve eight May yeah whatever
that is oh just just perfection yeah
perfect rule number nine assume that the
person you are listening to might know
something you don't
okay I have a little of that at the
moment yes well that's what a good
conversation is about it's like because
what do you want to do is you want to
enter into a conversation so that you
come out wiser than you went in and so
the best example of this is when you're
having an argument with your intimate
partner let's say it's like because
you're gonna want to win and then
especially if you get angry because
anger wants to win it's okay so then you
got to think okay well wait a second we
better show better sort out what winning
means here so let's say that you're more
verbally fluent than your partner and
more treacherous so you can win that
doesn't mean you're right first of all
that's a big problem winning when you're
wrong is a really bad idea because then
you think you're right and you're not
and then well maybe the person can see
things you can't but can't verbalize
them quite as well it's like well you
might want to listen just because
there's there's the possibility that
they're trying to tell you how to not to
run headlong into a brick wall there's
some possibility of that and so maybe
you even have to help them formulas like
okay I don't get exactly what you're
saying I don't get
exactly why you're annoyed I'm not sure
exactly what you want me to do to change
it let's get this clear and then I'm
gonna think about it's like maybe you're
right I'm gonna see if possibly you're
right I'm not gonna roll over cuz I
would rather you weren't right I'm not
gonna change
mm-hmm unless I'm convinced but I am
gonna listen because I would rather not
run headlong into a brick wall
if I don't have to and so that's the
idea with the conversation it's like and
this is I think why you're also supposed
to listen to your enemies it's because
your enemies will tell you like they'll
tell you all sorts of lies about you
that's not so good maybe you'll even get
confused about that but now and then
your enemies will tell you something
your friends won't and you think well
they told said ninety things about me
that weren't true and like two things
that were and so you separate the wheat
from the chaff and you think okay you
know okay maybe I was a little I tried
to learn that law in the last year you
know maybe I was a little too harsh in
that and I've had people talking to me
about my public appearances they're
watching and trying to help me not make
mistakes you know and then they call me
my friends they say well you know your
little arrogant there you you're a
little harsh there you're better when
you're not so angry you know you're
better when you're making some jokes and
I'm listening because well I'd rather
not have the mistake because their
mistakes could be fatal
mm-hmm so it's like let me no I don't
want to hear it
especially if it's a deep mistake
because then I've take myself apart and
that's no fun and maybe a bunch of me
has to burn off which is no fun but
listening well that's you know obviously
you're good at it because otherwise you
wouldn't be interested in this and your
show wouldn't be popular so you're doing
that obviously somehow I got one thing
right I like this one and I think I mean
this is very clearly what you do be
precise in your speech so in in Genesis
one of the things God has Adam do first
so God makes the world by speaking okay
so that's the first thing to think about
you're supposed to think like in a
sophisticated way about this the idea is
that some integral relationship between
communication and
structure of being it's part of the role
that consciousness plays in the world
whatever that role is language takes the
chaos and makes it into things and so
God has Adam named all the animals
they're not even really real until they
have names now they're more implicit
that's another you know here's here's an
example let's say that you're having a
rough patch in your relationship and you
don't know why it's unnameable is it
real well yeah it's manifesting itself
in it like a physiological discomfort
then you talk about it you name it it's
like it goes from this blurry thing
that's kind of potentially goes snap
mm-hmm and then it's this thing right
and then that's a horrible thing it's
like a little poisonous thing but it's
not a whole foggy cloud of potential
poison it's like this little sharp
poison thing then you think okay it's
real it's a little monster but it's not
it's little at least and now probably we
can do something about it if we can
admit to it so it's this precision that
specifies and like so this is a little
bit of the Voldemort effect right since
you're a Harry Potter guy they wouldn't
name right this is a problem we got to
name them first oh yeah you got to name
them first absolutely because the
unnameable is far more terrifying than
the nameable you see that in there was a
great Blair Witch Project terrifying
move oh yeah it's unnamed there's
nothing terrible happens in that movie
it's all there unnameable it's like
what's going on what's going on what's
going on and no matter how terrible the
actuality is it's rarely as terrible as
your imagination because your
imagination like it's an old thing it's
seen a lot of terrible things in the
history of life like it can put monsters
everywhere and so it's almost always
better it might be better without
exception to name the thing no matter
how terrible it is and if you can't name
it what that means is that you're you're
telling yourself that you're so
terrified that you can't bring your
attention to bear on it and that makes
you you're the loser
instantly if it's so terrifying that you
cannot face it it's one you know it's in
your
because just in the political sense I
think a lot of people listening or
probably thinking well this is
unfortunately one of the things that the
left has done with radical Islam where
they refused to talk about it name it
just name it so then Trump comes in and
he names it and then it's like well he's
the hero but all we wanted you to do if
you just can't even say the words then
how do we actually address the issues
well anything anything that's
threatening is like that like let's say
we want to specify something that's
threatening think well you know you
shouldn't be prejudiced against an
entire group of people it's like hey
fair enough man course yeah but ideas
have consequences and there is religious
conflict and there is terrorism it's
like okay what do we make of that well
the way you figure that out is you have
a conversation about it stupidly you
make all sorts of mistakes you might
even make racist mistakes it's like well
what is this thing how are we supposed
to get our hands around it how are we
supposed to know what it is well you
can't talk about it because that's bad
it's like it's not as bad as what you
conjure up if you can't talk about it
okay then it's the devil himself I mean
that's how we that's how we demonize
people the worst way of demonizing
people is to not be able to say anything
about them because then god only knows
what their unspeakable there isn't a
better synonym for what's terrifying
then that's unspeakable what you did was
unspeakable it's like no no you want to
bring things out of the realm of the
unspeakable that's why I'm a free speech
advocates yeah
part it's like bringing everything out
of the realm of the unspeakable because
it's also the direct attack on the
intellect isn't it it's a direct attack
if you can't speak about something you
can exercise just gonna make that box
around your brain that much wider deeper
than the intellect
it's an assault on whatever rule
consciousness has in being it's not just
the intellect like that's that that's
that's a shallower thing it's not like
it's not important it's it's you can't
even attend to it you can't bring it out
of the chaos like it means you you can't
participate in the process of creation
it's something that deep not good for
like freedom of speech that's that's the
worship of the logos in many
waise and you know that's that's a very
deep idea in our culture the deepest
idea of our culture is the logos is
creative and what it makes is good right
that's that's God at the beginning of
time saying you know he makes things as
a consequence of the logos and he says
it's good that's the idea is that to
bring things out of the murk is a good
thing you don't mess with that man
not unless you want murk you don't mess
with that it's the fundamental it's the
most sacred principle of Western
civilization and not only Western the
Daoists know this as well so yeah
there's a lot there all right two more
rule number 11 do not bother children
when they are skateboarding that's a
very specific one there yeah yeah it is
well that's it that's an essay about
masculinity mostly you know I used to
watch kids skateboard on st. George
Street which is kind of cool no because
obviously st. George is the Dragon
Slayer
that's the street I work on which i
think is quite funny and anyways these
kids used to you know there are
teenagers young teenagers we have these
long bar hand railings going down some
shallow stairs but it's fairly good
flight of them and they would boardslide
down these right was it's crazy it's
this concrete that's pebbled it's like
you don't want to land on that if you've
probably heard a lot of bones crunching
oh it's like you know but they didn't
have much protective gear on and you
know and eventually this the university
put up things to stop them you know from
doing this which I complain about in
this chapter for a bunch of reasons but
like I liked watching those kids I like
watching skateboarders do those crazy
things because they're trying to become
competent like in there they're facing
danger they don't want the damn
protective gear like sometimes it's just
stupidity it's like wear a damn helmet
you know but sometimes it's not it's
like no I don't want to wear a helmet I
want to expose myself to this danger
it's not that I'm stupid maybe it is you
know I'm just being careless right but
maybe it's not it's like no I I'm facing
the danger I'm trying to master it and
if you watch kids board slide down like
handrail
if you don't think that that's
courageous then your and maybe stupid
those two things aren't so easy to
distinguish yeah but it's brave and when
they do it it's like amazing it's it's
impossible to do that you jump in the
air you grab your skateboard you balance
on this stupid rail you slide for 20
feet and then you know the price for
failure is well you do the splits on the
rail that's not fun you know or you land
head first
I can change your masculine masculinity
like yeah I'm so like and the kids are
often shooed away it's like wait a sec
they're there practicing being
courageous they're practicing mastering
something in the face of danger you know
and a lot of the rebellious behavior of
young men in particular which is very
frowned upon in the schools it's like
that's toxic masculinity you know that
horrid horrid phrase mm-hmm it's like
leave those damn kids alone let them
like another thing I referred to in that
chapter is about 10 years ago in Toronto
they changed the insurance rules
governing the playgrounds and parents
had raised money for these damn
playground so there's nothing wrong with
them they tore them all out the whole
city like two weeks before school
started there was nothing but like dirt
and gravel
what happened Sauron rubber enough for
they were bouncy enough for they were
too unsafe who knows right who knows
what there was nothing wrong with them
you know well then the kids were I saw
the kids on top of the school so because
they needed some danger yeah we know
that kids on playground equipment they
will push to the limit of their ability
that's what you see what you like when
you go see a sport like gymnastics
mm-hmm you know you think you go see a
gymnast and like the gymnast does a
flawless routine and like everybody
claps like mad and you know though the
judges say nine point nine and it sits
and then the next person comes up and
they're screwed it's like nine point
nine it was basically perfect how can
you do better than perfect and then they
do it and and and you can do better than
perfect because so the person is like
they're on the edge and they go out
there and you know you watch them you
feel it in your body because you're
mimicking them physiologically you see
that every
they do is that much farther out into
chaos than anything they've ever done
right they're pushing themselves to the
absolute limit of their ability and
everyone's like this because you tell
with every gesture that they're that
close to making a mistake and so they've
taken this courageous step beyond their
competence mm-hmm and put everything on
the line and not celebrate in that and
then when they land they land in a way
that's unlike perfect perfect plus and
everybody immediately leaps to their
feet and like they get a chill right and
it's the same chill your hair stands on
end it's the same chill that a mouse has
when it looks at a wolf the mouse puffs
up its aw and so what you've just seen
is awe-inspiring cuz you've seen someone
courageously move past perfection into
the unknown and and not only ennoble
themselves more but to a noble humanity
itself and upon your feet it's like yes
and then it's tens right it's tens they
win the gold and it's like well everyone
knows what that's like it's like a great
musical performance and that's that's
being in that place where everything
lines up it's better than perfect
so better than perfect I don't know how
that we can end this then and this one
I'm a dog guy you've met my dog pet a
cat when you encounter one and on the
street well it's funny that you said
you're a dog guy because about the first
three pages of the chapter are actually
an apology for Norton
okay I start by talking about dogs quite
a bit obviously but well that is bit
autobiographical I talk up there a bit
about my daughter in that and she's
actually vetted the chapter and helped
me write it because I wrote about
tragedy really about pain and and well
in the pain of caring for someone
especially with children you know and
what you have to do when you're in a
situation where tragic things are
happening in front of you and you're
somewhat powerless in in the face of
them you know and part of that is you
have to keep your eyes open for
for the little opportunities for the
redemptive elements of being to sort of
pop themselves up so I talked a little
bit about this cat that's across the
street named ginger ginger is this
Siamese cats really friendly made
friends with our dog just by refusing to
be afraid they come over and the dog
would sort of bark and it would roll
over and like pawed you know so they
were friends in no time and the cat
would just come over and like let you
pet it and be happy with it for a minute
and that's when things are not good and
hard then you get these little moments
where a little bit of possibility still
shines through and you got to take those
moments when you get them and so that's
what that chapter is about it's about
how to manage when things are too much
and there's some practical advice in
there like one of the things you have to
do when things are just going to hell in
a handbasket let's say is you got to
also shrink your temporal horizon it's
like you know you think well I'm
planning three months out it's not not
if you're on fire you're planning for
the next two seconds mm-hmm you know and
if things are really harsh in your life
someone's suffering around you and you
got too many problems it's like you
shrink your timeframe to the day and you
try to or the hour or the minute you say
okay well we got to have the best next
minute we can have gonna have that's a
deathbed thing too right it's like you
sure you shrink the time until you can
handle it
there's no not any more going on in that
tiny fragment of time than you can bear
that's how you adjust to the catastrophe
and you try to stay on your feet and
react during those periods of time and
so it's a bit of a discussion about how
you reconfigure your perceptions of
things when when when there's too much
pain and trouble in your life so it's
it's actually a very positive chapter
yeah I know it deals with very you know
harsh things it was the most emotional
chapter to write I would say and my
daughter's actually doing quite well
she's figured out a lot of what was
wrong with her that's great an amazing
tour de force of of conscience
tration and care you know like I can't
believe she's managed it so it's a
positive thing that the chapter and and
you know it's a reminder to look for
what's meaningful and soul-satisfying
soil sustaining even when you're where
you'd rather not be so well listen I
could I mean I really could do ten hours
this and it would be no problem
whatsoever
we're gonna take a 60-second break we'll
do some audience questions hey you got
it in you sure let's do it this be over
a gin on the rocks or does that welcome
I think I'll wait till tonight when we
go out I think I - alright see you're a
man of discipline no it's mostly terror
yeah it's nice to be care it's a fine
line between terrorism sometimes is a
matter of being terrified of the right
things you know because yeah I really do
believe that it's like there's things to
be concerned about everywhere you want
to be concerned about the right things
and if you think through the
consequences of your misbehavior do you
really think it through then you get
your fear pushing you forward instead of
in front of you stopping you would this
be a bad time to tell you that this was
June all right guys 60 seconds we'll be
back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right I think that was 69 seconds 69
71 getting worse I'm wrong you see what
you did to me here all right
Peterson here we go we're gonna start
well first a quick super chat somebody
donated $6 of coffee for both of us
so we will have coffee in the morning
and another quick one Peterson you're a
hero professor never stop
you have no intentions to stop I know
that you don't have to even respond to
that one you want to tell the guy my
health holds out I should be able to
manage this fair enough
dr. Peterson can you this is patreon can
you recommend any good sources on the
connections between personality type and
political affiliation which model of
personality type is the most reliable in
this context big five the big five
extraversion neuroticism agreeableness
conscientiousness openness the the
Liberals are open and low in
conscientious conservatives are high in
conscientiousness Lowe and openness
openness is the creativity dimension
liberals and conservatives need each
other
the Liberals are entrepreneurial and
creative the conservatives are diligent
and and and implement things so that
that's why the temperamental niches
exist if you look up Big Five political
preference online you'll find papers
right away yeah I've never heard you
specifically call yourself anything
politically I think you're basically a
classical liberal and we had a funny
yeah in the Q & A when you were talking
about the difference between leftists
and liberals you're saying liberals have
not been good about it I'm trying yeah
I'm trying to help this quality
mystically liberals are described as
being right-wing by the radical left
types but I'm I'm kind of in mixed
because I'm very very high in openness
which is the best predictor of
liberalism but I'm also rather high in
conscientiousness so I've kind of got a
foot in each camp in some sense yeah so
and I I don't to the degree that I'm a
conservative it's more because I'm a
traditionalist not so much because I'm
by temperament I'm too like I'm not a
conservative thinker right you know I'm
a wild thinker actually so and that that
doesn't that doesn't go doesn't jive it
does Dylan job with that okay
patron dr. Peterson my husband and I are
acting our first child do you have any
thoughts on early childhood care for
working mothers should the mothers stay
home longer than typical maternity leave
allows even if she is the higher earner
in the household in the interest of
healthy psychological development that's
an interesting twist on this when it
comes directly to earning because I
think I know your answer well one
question might be whose psychological
development you know like it's a lot
harder on mothers to leave their infants
and go back to work then they typically
think like it's really rough and you
know you wonder to to what degree this
is speculation but as a protective
mechanism you know you don't want to be
divorcing yourself in some sense from
that intense relationship with your
child to soften the blow of having to go
back to work because you know you really
have to fall in love with your infant
and this really affects women it's a big
change
it's biochemical immediate to a large
degree for whatever that's worth but you
know children infants are a tremendous
amount of responsibility in trouble
because they can't do anything and you
have to be like seriously in love with
them to do right by them and then it'll
wrench your soul to two part too early
and so it's a it's a personal decision
you know like and it also depends on the
degree to which your partner is maternal
let's say cuz some men are not very some
women aren't very maternal
it's a temperamental thing some men are
more maternal than others if your
partner is capable of providing that
maternal care infants are perfectly
capable of forming multiple attachments
what they don't like is to have a
primary attachment disrupted because the
the person to whom the infant attaches
primarily is the infant's entire world
so when that person goes away their
entire world goes away mm-hmm so they
can have multiple closed attachments and
so if the father can get in there and
have it really tightly bonded attachment
and he can take over the roles although
I would say in my personal experience
it's very rare it's hard for men to do
right by infants for the first year
they're just they just don't have the
equipment they can do it but
but it's not easy it's not as built in
basically because we discussed this
alone they also don't have breasts which
actually turns out to be somewhat of a
problem yeah because breastfeeding
actually matters and there's a lot to
breastfeeding it's it's you know you
think it's just a matter of nutrition
it's not it's skin-to-skin contact it's
eye to eye gaze it's it's embodied
rhythm it's the beginnings of the
establishment of the relationship like
it's and that isn't to say that you
can't bottle feed but success right but
but breastfeeding also tends to produce
children who have higher IQs so that's
also worth knowing because it act that
actually matters yeah one of the things
that I asked you privately a couple
weeks ago because I was saying how you
talk about these things often in the
terms of sort of male/female yeah and
you may and I was telling you know as
you know I'm gay and married and my
husband is actually much more of a
nurturer and would be much better with
children yeah that I would want to be
analyst and you were very clear that
your position on all of this isn't that
it has to be a male and a female
but you were just talking about the
traits of masculinity and femininity and
sometimes they were very effeminate men
who happened to be straight and they're
a very masculine women who happened to
be female yes yes which I just think I
just think it's worth mentioning in all
this because I think people accuse you
sometimes of somehow your being you know
anti-gay or something in all this and I
mean look there are pronounced
personality differences between men and
women women are higher and negative
emotion and they're higher and trade
agreeableness and it's not small but
there's more difference within women and
difference within men than there is
between the groups it's true with almost
every group comparison so there can be
significant differences where there's
still enough individual variation so you
can't do a good job of categorizing a
person as a consequence say of their
gender mm-hmm you know like basically
with the agreeableness the difference is
enough so that if you took randomly
random sets of men and women over the
population and you said you bet on who
was more agreeable if you bet on the
woman you'd be right 60 percent of the
time hmm but that's like that's a
significant difference but you'd be
wrong forty percent of the time so this
is the problem this is one of the things
that the people who criticize James do
more for example they just they just
don't get it yeah is that the did and
they also don't get it with
damn diversity arguments I hate those
arguments diversity of race and gender
makes for diversity of opinion it's like
you can't have both of those beliefs at
the same time that's actually prejudice
it's actually wrong because there's more
difference within the groups than there
is between them otherwise I don't even
want to get started with that it's so
wrong yeah technically wrong it's not a
matter of political opinion it's wrong
yeah there's more difference within
people within groups of people than
there is between them otherwise we
couldn't even communicate and I like the
passion with which you're saying it
because this is why we know that social
justice and the diversity memo and all
of this nonsense is going to come into
direct conflict with biology oh yeah so
that's why your your lack of tolerance
for it is because you get it that's
already come into conflict with biology
these aren't I wouldn't say that these
are precisely theories no one was
thrilled about these discoveries like
they're hard nosed statistically derived
agnostic knowledge statements and he's
like no one knew that when the
Scandinavians produced more equitable
societies that the personality
differences between men and women would
get bigger no one thought that no one
predicted it no one was happy about it
it just happened
there's no there's nothing political
about it in fact quite the contrary
because most of the people who
discovered this if you would have asked
them what their preferences were because
they'd be more liberal leaning they
would have said they would have
predicted a well if you make societies
more equitable men and women are gonna
get more the same obviously right it
seems obvious and yes that would be a
good thing it's like well obvious or not
it was wrong and it's reliable because
the people who discovered it wouldn't
have wanted it that way
mm-hmm they weren't beating they weren't
conservatives saying oh well we have to
still be in the difference between men
and women it was like oh my god that
happened we've had to replicate that
because it seems unlikely well it took a
long time even for people to figure out
how that could possibly be the case the
answer was well men and women differ for
two reasons environmental and genetic if
you take all the differences out of the
environment all you're left with is the
genetic differences they maximize
it's like oh that makes sense we didn't
predict it we wouldn't have guessed it
but how else could it be
well it could be that there were no
genetic differences well right the fact
that women have like functioning breasts
and men don't that's actually a genetic
difference there are genetic differences
so the hate speech never ends with you
huh yeah it's just all right after
another super chat this is this is a
great question Dave wish you and Jordan
well what are your biggest criticisms
currently and how do each of you respond
so I'll let you go first I actually
wonder this isn't directed yeah directed
at you if I talk too much
that's one yeah especially if I'm
interviewing people or having a
discussion with them I I can get
irritable and angry and that's not
optimal and I've had lots of discussions
with people like I'm better when I'm
calm and and collected and and friendly
you know but I use anger to some it's
fairly well integrated in me and I use
it as a way of overcoming fear say which
is one thing anger does by the way
because it suppresses fear circuitry so
but I haven't got the belt that balance
exactly right I forget things that's
another thing what else what else I take
on more things than I can probably
attend to properly and that's openness
it's like I'm interested in everything
so it's easy for me if I'm healthy I can
do a lot and stay on top of a lot but I
don't leave much of a margin for error
and so if my health declines a bit I'm
really in trouble because I've got all
these balls in the air so I probably
work more than I should
and that's hard on my wife mm-hmm and
that's really been exaggerated in the
last year that's that's not too bad oh
I'm susceptible now and then and have
been through my whole life I really like
alcohol I really have to be careful
about that and I am but I know for a
fact you are but it's a but it's a
temptation
[Music]
that'll do for now that'll do for now I
would say for me I think the biggest the
question was about the biggest criticism
I think the biggest criticism I get and
it's from a very small minority but I do
get it is that people sometimes want me
to browbeat my guests more they want me
to be a little more combative or fight
with people more it's just it's a it's
not my nature as a human being it's also
just not my approach to to interviewing
it was a criticism you know my friend
and mentor Larry King he used to get
that criticism too I always find that
sitting across from someone listening to
them asking the right follow-up
questions really understanding their
line of thinking and knowing what the
next good question is I think is a much
more effective way than browbeating them
but in terms of criticism it is
something that I hear and as I as I
often say in live streams it's like
maybe I'll look back five years where
you know I'm doing this in ten years
maybe I'll look back and go man there
were moments I could have done this yeah
and I'm not perfect and I want to change
and I hope I'm better in five years the
night well you can get in trouble like
faith Goldie who worked for rebel media
gun trouble she's pretty agreeable she's
tough but she's agreeable and then she
went talked to these like white
supremacist types and she justified that
on the grounds that she was a journalist
this was down in Charlottesville she was
the one who got right right she was the
one who caught the footage of the
vehicle right so you know she had every
reason to assume that it was okay for a
journalist to be there but she went on
this far right show and she was too
agreeable you know she was kind of
joking and laughing and and conducting
the interview and in the manner that you
just described and you know she really
got cut off at the knees for that and
because the idea was well in that
situation she had an ethical
responsibility to be hard-ass and to ask
penetrating questions and you know I
think it was temperament in large part
that got her in trouble but but well
yeah and I think there's there's some
legitimacy to all that and you know it's
it's if I was sitting across you were a
white supremacist of course I would be
questioning you differently and trying
to figure out your motives differently
than someone that comes from your
background yeah well it's harder than
people think though because you know if
when you meet the devil himself he's a
lot more like you than you think and if
you're a polite person and you're a
polite person and you have decent
manners it's not an easy thing to go and
on someone's leg even if you
oh that because most of them is quite a
lot like you and so there's it's not
easy to come out and attack someone
especially if you're a compassionate
relatively compassionate person mm-hmm
so I mean sometimes that's obviously
necessary especially if you're a
journalist but yeah I think people find
it very easy on Twitter that seems to be
the place sure
relentlessly like honking your horn
behind the safety of your windshield
it's like that's easy
exactly all right we'll jump back to
patreon dr. Peterson at 33 years old and
living in expensive Southern California
with now three young children what is
your advice on how to balance having a
parent at home with our children versus
pursuing dual incomes there's a little
bit more to that and we sort of hit on
this with the other one but it's another
interesting one how all of these things
about personal responsibility and
children they're so related to economic
oh the one thing you want to think about
with children especially young children
this is really important you got to get
this right when you have a baby say it's
you can't believe it and you can't
believe that you're gonna be able to
figure out what to do with this thing
like it's like it's the most complicated
thing you've ever had and no one has
helped you figure out how to do it so
you're stuck and then like three months
later it's like you can't really imagine
what life would be like without that
baby and then it's sort of like this
goes on forever that's how it feels but
it doesn't right you have little kids
for four years and if you miss it it's
done that's it so you're gonna know that
it's you know lots of things in life you
don't get to do more than once now
obviously you can have more than one
child but all I'm saying is that period
between zero and four zero and five
there's something about it that's really
it's like a pink experience in life and
as much of your life you know because
you think of it the law is a long time
it's not that long man four years goes
by so fast you can't believe it and if
you miss it it's gone so you miss it at
your peril and you don't get it back and
that's not I know it with your career
you miss opportunities you fall behind
this happens to women a lot it's part of
the reason for the pay gap and it's
really hard on women you know although
no one knows what to do about it
so and I would also say well you talk to
each other try to minimize your your
financial requirements to the degree
that you can see if there's other ways
that you could generate income but and
do your come to a consensual solution
and try not to torture yourself with
guilt with whatever you come up with but
do remember because you know you've got
financial responsibilities and often you
need two incomes and there's there's no
easy way of dealing with it and for
women it you often seems that no matter
what they do it's wrong right they stay
home with the kids it's wrong if they go
to work it's wrong if they do both it's
wrong and I'm like I'm not being smart
about that that's rough man but I but
having said all that I would say again
you got little kids for four years don't
miss it you will regret it
so yeah all right we'll try to knock a
couple quick ones out and then we'll get
into some of the longer ones superjet
have you ever thought about teaching
creative writing that's an interesting
one no I don't have the expertise to do
that
super tattle so King George the dragon's
lair a fitting Street for the father we
all one day claim aim to be Thank You
dr. Peterson all right so that was
that's nice to hear another one Jordan
thank you for sharing your wisdom your
lectures did change my life yeah now
we're in the accolades portion here
really
hi Jordan Peterson I believe there's a
growing number of an caps free market
anarchists that are trying to influence
society I would like to know your
opinions on them and how we should keep
them from thrusting us into chaos
so they editorialize the little area
there at the end well these people that
basically want to get rid of government
altogether well you can't get rid of
government because government is is just
an expression expression of the
necessity for groups of people to reach
a consensus about how they're going to
behave there's no getting rid of that a
family has a government if it doesn't it
has unspoken rules then there's a ritual
so the governor if there's no government
it's ritual but
families are actually better when some
of the government is governing
principles are articulated so you know
any to get to the proper place usually
means to balance a number of competing
forces
it isn't like well no government and
everything will be okay it's like no
sorry that's not that isn't it isn't
that simple
mmm-hmm and nothing is that simple
that's why I'm not a fan of ideologue
sits like any logs have the same answer
to every question it's like well that's
the same as not thinking generally it
turns out that things are very very
complicated and you have to take them
apart in detail and then you have to
solve a small part of the problem and
that's hard it's like everything is like
fixing a military helicopter there's a
lot of parts and you don't understand
most of them and you'll make it worse if
you don't know what you're doing and so
those those movements like anarchists or
progressives or or it's like no it's too
complicated yeah it's interesting
because I've had a couple and caps on
here
intellectually I love the exercise of
how much could we chop away from the
government but the for me at least as
someone that believes we have to have
some level of government the the chaos
that we would go through and the pain
and probably bloodshed and God knows
what else
just wouldn't be worth even getting
there but I like the idea necessary to
figure out how to limit the growth of
anything that has the proclivity to grow
and and I'm not a fan of bigness no
there is this idea especially around
2008 of too big to fail I think of all
the bloody phrases that have ever been
coined that has to be one that's nearest
to the stupidest because the actual in
my opinion the proper viewpoint on that
is that it's so big it has to fail and
so this is one of the things that I
think could actually unite conservatives
and liberals or conservatives and left
it's even it's like leftists don't like
big companies and conservatives don't
like big government's like okay there's
something in common there big well big
is a problem I really think this is part
of the reason for brexit is like the
peon economic community was too big it's
it's and and that means the separation
between the citizen and the ruler
there's so many levels in between it
that there's no communication and that's
what happens to that's the Tower of
Babel mm-hmm right if it gets so big it
doesn't work anymore and so and so that
you know too much governments like no no
too big a monopoly ah well you see this
starting to happen with Google and
Facebook
ya know on there playing games YouTube -
yeah and games well it's funny because I
then see a lot of conservatives saying
well we need to break them up and my
thought is well wait a minute do I want
the government now to tell these
companies what to do well sometimes yeah
so that's I struggle with that one I
don't really exist that struggle with it
exactly yeah well you know you got
demonetized it's very interesting how
close that word is to demon bath day I
really get a kick out of well you can't
say demonetised without demons that's
right you know it's funny though the
too-big-to-fail thing what did what was
their answer they made them all bigger
hmm I know that oh they did they're too
big to fail so what are we gonna do
we'll make them bigger I mean it just it
doesn't even stand to reason okay couple
more a super check quick Jordan I'm a
master's student in mathematics how do I
know whether or not to enter academia
how do I know I will be smart or
creative enough it's interesting second
part of that well I like that teach
because that would be good do you do you
like to do research and write writing is
really important if you don't like to
write well or the equivalent in
mathematics I mean it's publishing
papers if you don't like to sit down and
do that if you're not compelled by ideas
ridiculously and if you don't like to
teach get the hell out because that's
what it is and it's getting harder in
academia not easier and the positions
are getting worse not better by a lot
yeah that's why I was so refreshing to
be a Clemson where we met some not only
do we make great students but there were
some academics there and some professors
that really they got it and they wanted
to fight for the right thing yes yes so
I would say if you're in love with ideas
and and and you're inspired by teaching
it's like they're you know you're the
you're the guy or you're the girl or
but otherwise don't do it this is a
sidebar from that one from patreon dr.
Peterson I'm relatively new I'm a
relatively new assistant professor in
physics I'm concerned not only for
myself but for my students about the
current situation on college campuses
what can a physics or astronomy class
provide by the way of curriculum or
approach that is currently lacking in
other areas of campus so that my
students can recapture some of what they
are missing well I think that that with
those disciplines you can give people a
sense of the grandeur of being you know
I mean there's the mathematical element
of it and the pure scientific element
but the great scientists are overcome by
awe constantly right I mean that's
what's driving them forward and
certainly it was with something like
astronomy I mean that's just it's right
there at your grasp and I think that's
the romanticist that's the romantic side
of science and there's a and that's
science as a calling in science as an
aesthetic experience and there's
absolutely no reason not to not to
capitalize on that you know and what you
want to do really is you want to share
your love of the discipline you want to
model your love of the discipline then
you're so as well as teaching the the
facts and the and the rituals of the
discipline your modeling engagement with
with that set of phenomena and ideas and
and that's that that that's what a
teacher should do that's what a
university teacher should do you're
there as an embodiment of the practice
of the discipline and so you want to
show that as part of a rich life and you
want to make people excited about doing
it so you have to be excited about doing
it and that's a big deal that's the
apprenticeship part it's a big deal this
is particularly interesting I think
because when we did this event at
Clemson it was through the iron Rand
Institute and they said to us they've
said to me because I've done a bunch of
them we don't you know do whatever you
want they just like what I'm doing they
like the Free Speech thing they invited
you on they didn't tell you to do it
unless they secretly did they all right
so the question is dr. Peterson I'm very
curious as to your opinion on
objectivism and the philosophies of iron
Rand it's the one thing I've never heard
pop up in your lectures and it's great
to have you back here
Dave so you mentioned nine RAM briefly
but you were talking about sort of the
the fiction writing um do you have any
thoughts on objectivism generally or the
sort of greater philosophical part of it
well I like the emphasis on individual
responsibility you know I think that's
very important and I like also although
this is still more the fiction element
you know I I think she was actually more
powerful as a fiction writer than as a
philosopher and that that's that's not
that's not a denigrating comment because
I don't believe that philosophy is a
higher calling than fiction you know
it's it's they're there they have their
own domains I think my my sense is that
I don't regard Iran as a great mind I
don't I don't think that her take on
things was sufficiently differentiated
and sophisticated I like I said I do
she had reasons to be anti-communist man
and and like Pat for sure she there are
plenty of reasons to be anti-communist
so I can certainly and I can resonate
with her critiques of that collectivism
and and I like the romanticism in the
books I enjoyed reading outlet shrugged
and I read it again recently I enjoyed
it again you know but but I also don't
think it's great literature and the
reason for that is that she doesn't
place the struggle between good and evil
inside her characters it's always
between characters and that's a mistake
because like even your most radical
left-wing revolutionary is mostly not a
radical left-wing revolutionary right
right you mean it's obviously home
watching Seinfeld in doing this yeah
exactly exactly and and and so you have
to show the struggle within more and I
don't think she does a very good job of
that her noble people are too noble and
her ignoble people are too ignoble and
it divides the world too much into the
bad guys and the good guys and it's like
that's comforting
I mean it's there's an archetypal
element to it - but it's not
sufficiently differentiated enough or
sophisticated enough no it's interesting
because I know that if any of the the a
RI people are watching this they'd be
happy to continue that conversation with
you publicly like that
that's what it's all about so that's
that's nice super chat dr. Peterson
please can you come to my school in
England we were falling down the rabbit
hole and I need your wisdom to be spread
throughout the UK please consider a UK
tour they didn't tell us what school but
will you consider a UK tour well I I
hope to be going many places in the next
year especially after this book comes
out which is in end of January so I'm
sure that my publicists and all those
people are gonna be shipping me
everywhere and well I would I would
really like to know the UK better yeah
and we're thinking about possibly doing
yeah thing together so we'll see if we
can get across the pond sure it'll
happen yeah oh I love this question dr.
Peterson this is patreon have you
thought of the idiocracy scenario for
example smart people get few children
dumb people get many average
intelligence fails over the generations
did you ever see that movie idiocracy
yeah so that's basically the question
like are we destined for it in a sense
tragically besides that all bets are off
for the future fundamentally I mean
things are gonna change so much in the
next thirty years either for they could
go terribly wrong I mean North Korea
could explode at any moment right I mean
we've got problems that could be very
very serious but we're also going to
undergo a wave of technological
revolution that's gonna make what's
already happened look like nothing and
so I don't even know what people will be
like in a hundred years I really I can't
I have no idea what human beings will be
like in a hundred years
they'll be augmented in all sorts of
ways assuming that you know we're not
all living in the rubble so no I
wouldn't I wouldn't I don't worry about
the future because I don't know what to
worry about really it's like I figured
this out about 20 years ago it's like I
have no idea what's gonna happen next
it is absolutely unpredictable that's
also why I ask people to sort of
concentrate to suggest to people that
they concentrate on that domain of
phenomena that they can actually
directly affect because really all bets
are off man so yeah but the probability
that we're gonna breed ourselves into
stupidity I think is pretty low perfect
we might end up in a dystopia where
we're served badly by really annoying
robots I'm pretty sure that now is a
definite I'm gonna be like the robots
all be like those you know when you
phone someone now yeah
that's what the robots they'll be like
they'll almost be helpful man I was
feeling hopeful now you gave me the most
dystopian thing possible super chat what
can be done from a strategic sense to
combat the postmodern movement for
example something like hashtag gamergate
which was reasonably effective I have a
answer but I'm gonna let you go okay
obviously well I I think that combating
it fundamentally is probably a mistake
it goes along now it's not like I've
sorted this out completely because I am
I dabble a bit in the political realm
like I'm fighting a war right now in
Canada with the Ontario Law Society
which has made it mandatory for its
members on pain of losing their license
essentially to come out with the
statement of principles a voluntary
statement of principles that's in
accordance with progressive doctrine
it's like no how about no where are you
guys at with that cuz last night you
were really cuz last I spoke to you just
a couple weeks ago you you were sort of
hopeful well I'm I'm not not hopeful
it's just that this thing is many
tentacle than work like concentrating on
one but but there's been lots of press
coverage of lots of criticism of the Law
Society lots of lawyers rebelling I've
got another video where I talk to a
couple of Ontario lawyers that's up on
YouTube I haven't released it yet like
we're fighting with it but but but I
don't think the political realm is the
right realm I think the battle we're
fighting is actually philosophical and
even theological I really believe that
and I think the right thing for people
to do I truly believe this is to get
their damned acts together this is I
don't think we're gonna get out of this
by fighting between left and right about
who's right or even by delimiting the
left I think we're gonna have to go
around them even and maybe that'll
happens but that's partly why I'm
interested in starting this online
university which now that I have some
more energy and I'm feeling better I've
got a whole bunch of ideas about again I
think you go look there's this line in
the New Testament says resist not evil
right it's like okay what the hell does
that mean that's a complicated one but I
think what it means is that you amplify
your enemy by
fighting against them because you admit
that they're worth fighting at these
gives a legitimacy yes you do yeah you
do and then it also distracts you from
doing other things that you could be
doing that would be better and like I
look at the university and I think well
can it be fixed what's doing a lot of
things wrong well maybe it shouldn't be
fixed maybe something else that this
matter should be put in its place now
that's not a simple thing maybe it's not
even possible but I think your efforts
are better spent fixing what you have
already at hand I really believe that I
think that's the right pathway yeah I
love that answer because when I was when
I was in the progressive world which I
was part of for a long time one of the
things that exhausted me and really led
to my awakening was that it was always
about complaining about someone else not
what are we doing not what how do we
make ourselves better how do we figure
out what's right it was always at Fox
News just doing this other my logo and
it was like all right I get that you can
do that a little bit but you can't that
sells you crazy
yeah you know I found myself falling
into that repeatedly yes well they
always lay crap doors right well I don't
like it like that's it's it's the wrong
entanglement you know and and it can
make you bitter that's another thing and
fearful that's bad and mistrustful
that's not good so I think it's better
Slyke repair what you can now and and
and you know I had to get political
let's say a year ago because I felt that
the government was doing something that
interferes with something that I
regarded a sacred let's say like which
is the right for me to formulate my own
damn language without threat of penalty
but I'm not happy about that about that
necessity nor about being involved in
this law thing so there's times when the
political structure is so damn unstable
and things are twisting around that it
intervenes in a way that you can't
ignore and then I don't think you can
ignore it but that doesn't take away
from my fundamental belief that enough
pointing your finger at what other
people are doing wrong in the world it's
like yeah fix something instead it goes
to that alternate title
offered you get your [ __ ] together yeah
twelve ways to get your [ __ ] yeah there
you go
patreon dr. Peterson I'm father of a 15
year old girl who's wanting to study
psychology at University how can I
advise her to gain resistance to
post-modernism while still pursuing her
interests in psychology that's easy ask
her to make sure that she master
statistics it's really important and and
she might not be temperamental II
inclined to do that because lots of
psychology students aren't get a tutor
if necessary get your damn statistics
and then concentrate on the on the
elements of psychology that have at
least one foot in biology stay on the
biological end clinical is pretty good
too or at least it was I don't know to
what degree it's got warped but if the
discipline has one foot in the in the
sciences then it's much safer and it's
it's more rigorous and then you can you
can move out from there into the other
sub disciplines like social psychology
which is quite corrupt but if you if
you're grounded in the biology and the
statistics then you've got the mental
tools and the constraints necessary to
keep yourself oriented properly yeah
this is interesting because this is
where I see I really love the the Joe
Rogan with you and Brett Weinstein and
he's grounded in science so you're not
going to beat him with cries and social
justice because he's grounded actually
in science hello dr. Peterson are there
any good ways to increase your levels of
conscientiousness keep up the great work
well I think you've been sort of hitting
that all of this is well I would say one
thing is do the self or through program
the Future authoring that'll help yeah
we have documented now I don't know if
it specifically makes you more
conscientious yeah but at least it makes
you act out the routines that a
conscientious person would act out yeah
oh by the way we're gonna put a link to
it right down below and if they enter
code Rubin all caps right yeah there's
there's a discount they get a 20%
discount on the two-for-one self are
three special which gives them the
autobiography that's passed authoring
the analysis of their faults and virtues
and the future authoring which is a
future plan that helps okay so we're
gonna put in the in the description
below so it's self authoring calm yeah
Rubin in all caps yes that's one thing
do the future authoring program because
that'll help
it'll rent see orient you and it makes
you more efficient because he can't hit
something unless you're aiming at it
then the other thing I would say is
learn to use a schedule a calendar like
Google Calendar and use it as if it's
your friend not your tyrant so the way
you use a schedule is you design days
that you would like to have and so some
of that has to be responsibilities and
those are things you have to do or your
life gets worse so you have to schedule
those in but you also schedule in you
try to design days that you would like
to have if you were taking care of
yourself and it's get like it'll if you
don't use the schedule to take you like
a 18 months to two years to get expert
at it it's hard but that will help you
immensely because you're basically
consciously figuring out how to use your
time so if you use the future authoring
program to figure out what it is that
you want and why and then you figure out
how to utilize your time properly and
then practice it you know if you're
scatterbrained and you procrastinate
it's gonna take you a long time to get
disciplined but you can do it and if you
failed and do it again and if you fail
then do it again and you know don't
don't torture yourself to death if you
fall off the wagon say yeah it's just
back on the schedule back on the
schedule you know it's interesting
because fortunately I have my guys that
my team not all guys my team that helps
me deal with my schedule so I sort of
give the general idea of I can do a lot
this day but then I might need a little
more time this day of downtime or that
sort of thing but yeah getting us just
getting a schedule in order so you're
not in this endless chaos
oh yeah it's a huge it's yeah but you
got to think about the schedule the
schedule is not a tyrant it's your
friend it's like I want to have the life
that would be best for me whatever that
is you know and it's not impulsive does
its that would do me the best as a being
okay I have to figure out how to do that
day by day schedule and those
computerised schedules those things are
great they're really simple to use
get be expert at it all right super chat
what advice would you give a young
graduate student pursuing a PhD in the
humanities
should I give up on that field that's a
great question because it's a really we
go inside read the greats like read the
classical canon read great literature
educate yourself you know and and become
an expert in postmodern thought great
you know like you need to give the devil
his due let's say but I mean an hour
online will tell you what you should
read I have a reading list on my website
at Jordan B Peterson calm you know
that's a good place to start it's by no
means comprehensive but they're books
that have really had an impact on me
read the other thing is write every day
every single day like you got to get
religious about that an hour an hour and
a half whatever you can steal from the
rest of your life
write down what you think pick a problem
and try to start sketching it out and
remember that you know as a scholar PhD
student you're basically educating
yourself and you have this time to read
and write and so and the humanities
there's nothing wrong with knowing about
post-modernism but it's really bad if
that's if you believe it I know and if
that's all you know that's not good at
all you're not educated at all you're
just an ideological puppet my fear of
bringing a child into this world in this
is from patreon sorry my feet my fear of
bringing a child into this world is
chaos and an authoritarian society I've
had that feeling since I was a child I
am so ready to fight am i right for this
fear oh yeah you should be afraid of
bringing a child into the world
obviously I mean one of the images I use
in the book is Mary the Pieta
Michelangelo it's it's illustrated by
Ethan Van Sciver who's a famous comic
book artist and it's a great sculpture I
mean it's amazing it's oh it's Mary and
she's holding the body of her adult son
who's being tortured to death and is
dead in her arms you know it's rough man
it's rough and what is this sculpture
mean it means that Mary Mother's
voluntarily offer up their children to
be broken by the world that's what you
do if you're a mother it's an off
some responsibility if you do it
consciously should you do it the answer
is it depends on how you do it and why
you do it and how you orient your
children you know you want to be a
mother in a way that justifies having
children and then you want to raise your
children to act in a manner that
justifies being human you should be
terrified of bringing children into the
world what you don't have any sense if
you're not I mean there's bad things
will happen to them
things that will break your heart so
it's like unbelievably and you don't
want to be naive
oh it's all wonderful it's like no it's
not that's not the point you do it
consciously you do it courageously just
like you trust people when you're no
longer naive this is a really important
thing to know why trust people when you
can be hurt it's like you trust them as
a manifestation of your courage in their
potential so you offer your hand and say
look I'm willing to trust you I can call
the best out of you with trust and I
know I can be knifed as a consequence
but you don't get the best without the
trust and society crumbles and
everything goes to hell it's so it's an
act of courage and that's the same with
having a baby it's an act of courage
this is good because I don't think I've
ever heard you talk about this from
super chat what are your thoughts on the
death penalty am I wrong to think the
Canada should happen oh well the first
thing is there's crimes that the proper
penalty is obviously death obviously
like I've read a lot about serial
killers for example ID law read a lot of
brutal material you know I was very
interested in criminology and antisocial
behavior as well as political pathology
it's like there are guys like I think
was John Wayne Gacy who yeah you don't
want to know about him I think he begged
the judge for the death penalty he knew
himself is like there was no coming back
from where he went
hmm so but that's not the issue for me
the issue is do you give the state that
much power and I would say practically
no I think this is a very callous way of
looking I think in the United States it
cost 20 million dollars to put someone
to death it's like why well because the
state shouldn't just be able to do that
easily and they make mistakes like a lot
of mistakes
so you got to get your your your theory
about this right
are there crimes that warrant death yes
like violent rape might be one of those
you know and and there's certainly
crimes that go beyond that I mean if you
have a daughter mother someone you love
who's raped violently and you're not
homicidally enraged by that there's
something wrong with you it's up to the
state to take that burden off of you
with the sufficient penalty and maybe
that penalty should be death but then
there's the state it's like who's the
monster here the criminal or the state
it's like well the criminal for sure but
also the state and so maybe you just
never want the state to have that much
power and I think that's a reasonable
argument no I that that's where instable
with them that's what the where I'm at
with it I just don't want to give the
state that power so I'm against the
death penalty but I understand I mean
I've had Dennis Prager in here who is
pro-death penalty and give the the full
argument on why that some things are so
they are no there's just absolutely no
doubt about that
I mean if you you just have to casually
read that the proper criminal III
outline a person in my in my book are
his name was oh hell no and I'm not
going to be able to remember anyways he
was brutalized when he was a kid he was
delinquent panzram carl panzram
fascinating autobiography and he was
brutalized when he was a delinquent rape
and and and tortured and all of that in
that reform home and he came out of
there like he was a very powerful guy
very big guy and he came out of there
seriously unhappy and he spent his whole
life producing nothing but mayhem and
his dying words were he was being hung
said hurry up you who's your bastard I
could tilt I could kill 10 men in the
time it takes you to hang me Wow yeah
and he said I wish the human race had
one collective neck so that I could put
my hands around it and choke Wow those
were his dying words it's like he was a
seriously bad guy you know and like
there was nothing to do with him Eric he
not only did he deserve the death
penalty he did everything he possibly
could to deserve it
consciously and and malevolently and
that's I talk about
him in the chapter about getting your
house in order before you criticize the
world but that's not the issue it isn't
the issue it's not the case that there
are things that are so vile that you
shouldn't be around anymore there are
things that are so vile that you know
you shouldn't be around anymore not the
issue in my estimation all right you
know we're gonna do we're new five
minutes more will have taken us to an
even three hours all right and then
we're gonna do one other thing a patreon
exclusive thing all right here we go dr.
Peterson how does your definition of
truth as you outlined on the waking up
podcast enrich your arguments for free
speech well that's that that might take
us home that's a complicated question
Sam Harris walk in right now and we want
it well look partly what you're trying
to do in life is to provide yourself
with the best possible set of tools okay
and so those are perceptual tools and
practical tools to move forward through
life and live properly well the free
speech is there isn't a difference
between free speech and thinking and
there isn't a difference between
thinking and making tools that that's
what it's about thinking it's not about
describing the objective world this is
the conversation that I was having with
Harris Lee yeah it's about a described
in the objective world but only insofar
as that's useful for us to live no so
it's nested inside this tool development
and so but and so to the degree that
free speech is required to think and
thinking is required to make tools or to
remove obstacles which is approximately
the same thing then the two are
integrally related and it isn't free
speech isn't the freedom to speak it's
the freedom to think and you might say
well why should people be able to think
and the answer to that is because they
let stupid thoughts die instead of them
that's Karl Popper it's very very smart
it's technically correct
so you're condemning people to suffering
and even death if you don't let them
speak thoughts a collective process this
isn't this conversation this is thinking
what we've
it's not like you had all these thoughts
and I had all these thoughts and we're
just bringing them forward we're
creating the thoughts on the fly and
refining them and communicating them
it's like you interfere with that you
interfere with the logos you you stop
chaos from being turned into order it's
like that's bad it's a bad thing so I
feel that that's the appropriate
question to end this on yeah I I do have
to tell you I you know for the hundreds
of interviews that I've done I have to
say that and perhaps this one being at
the at the top of all of the ones that
we've done together I find that I get so
much out of what you talk about and I
think that so I truly understand why
people are why you are resonating with
people the way that you are because the
clarity that you talk about the the
vulnerability that you don't know
everything all of those things I mean
what the reason I do this is I want to
be better as a person and it's really to
sit here for three hours it was like
that and and I suspect we will shall do
it again III hope so well I would also
like to say to like I don't I read this
essay by Carl Jung called relations
between the ego and the unconscious
that's a very important essay but you
can't understand it unless you kind of
know what it's about and you were warns
about inflation ego inflation narcissism
you know and so people are writing me
saying well you've changed my life and
you know and I'm popular and having this
positive effect it's like wow I'm so
great it's like no no no no no no I'm
fortunate because I've been able to
articulate these ancient ideas and the
ancient ideas aren't me they're not me
they're seriously not like I'm I'm like
I said I'm fortunate that I can
articulate them and there and that helps
transfer the power of them to other
people the people already know them in
some sense they resonate with them but
but it's very important to maintain a
distinction between being the messenger
and the message and and I'm not the
message although to some degree I'm
fortunate enough to be the messenger and
it's this essay of young it was a life
changer for me because it's it's
brilliant it's absolutely brilliant he
says very clearly
discipline yourself be careful with your
life and do not confuse archetypal ideas
with yourself it's like right yes don't
do that it's bad idea Hitler did that
Stalin did that Mao did that you do not
do that so on that note it's been a
pleasure thank you guys for watching
we're gonna do one extra thing if you
are a patreon member if you're not you
can jump over to patreon.com/crashcourse
air will be Jin how about that sounds
good later on so there shall be Jen all
right thanks guys
[Music]
you